Don't do the techone thing. Oh my god. If I had to listen to
this guy go, "Guys, I unplugged from the Matrix for like 3 hours
and now I can see how how blinded everybody else is by hatred."
He can't even effectively like concern troll over Charlie because
he just keeps bringing it back to himself every time >> on
a daily basis. >> I don't It's a bit, right? It has to
be. It just has to be a bit. I don't understand. He didn't understand
what real pain was today until he saw what happened to Charlie.
Okay. He was getting his tattoo. He didn't know what real pain
was. And we thought that was, you know, he saw Charlie die, but
it wasn't Charlie dying that caused him pain. Actually, it was
him realizing that he suffers even worse than Charlie did. Okay?
That people call him a and he doesn't get to end his suffering
like Charlie did. He has to be called a every day for the rest
of his life. And that's the real pain.
Anyway, hold on. We got another We got a Drew Pavlau tweet. Drew
Pavloo.
Mr. Pavloo. What does Mr. Pavloo have to say? Mr. Pavlau himself.
Anybody on the left who disavows the murder of Charlie Kirk is
weak. Destiny. This is evil, dude. Omniomol liberal. Absolutely
zero humanity. He literally had the exact same job as you. He
was a political
Oh, we got a wider blast on this. Let's check it out. And Destiny
is scum, man. That's why I stopped associating with him. Yeah,
I like this guy. This guy's kind of cool. This is like a wider
clip. I wasn't sure with the dickers one how wide the clip was.
>> What do you think conservative response to this will
be? Um, it's going to be the exact same response that it always
is. It's going to be uh blaming the left. It's going to be a
call for more aggressive rhetoric towards the left. It's going
to be a call for the left to condemn or disavow whatever the
anybody on the left that does any sort of disavow whatever bull
I think is weak. I I saw Do we have Do we have like a bigger
response here from anybody? Cuz this feels like 190,000 likes
on this bad boy. This guy might be honestly this guy might be
one of the biggest influences on the right right now. And this
guy is a known This is like Charlie Kirk's sworn enemy. Nobody
hated Charlie Kirk more than this guy. Okay, Charlie Kirk is
to Nick Fentes as Hassan is to Destiny. Okay, Nick Fentes built
his career off of going after Charlie Kirk and calling him a
fraud.
That's like how he first came onto the scene. And this was his
response. So, I just find it like a little crazy that Desi could
sit here and say, "No, they're going to call for more violence.
They're going to call for more." Yeah, some people will, but
like it's not going to be the overwhelming majority of people.
190,000 likes. Okay. Yeah, 190,000 likes. I think he's about
to call it not so >> disavow whatever bull I think is weak.
I I saw Newsome doing it earlier >> and not so nuome. >> Um
no I at some point >> Oh, hold on. Hold on. >> Disavow
whatever I think is weak. I I saw Newsome doing it earlier. No,
I at >> Oh, I just clicked on his Twitter.
>> I think it's weak. I I saw Nome doing it earlier. Um,
no,
>> at some point.
If I hear any mainstream conservatives say, "We need to bring
the temperature down." Um, then then I'll start taking it seriously.
But until then, nah, [__] that. Oh, tons of mainstream
conservatives have said that though. Like absolutely tons of
mainstream conservatives have said, "We need to start doing this."
Another because he just avoids conservatives talking.
Probably, probably, probably. Not a single large conservative
figure today will talk about toning down the rhetoric on their
side. It will be endless posts about civil war and revenge until
we forget about it and move on to the next thing. And your opponent
crosses the Rubicon from rhetoric to murder. There is no toning
down. Watch who are celebrating tonight. This guy's also
bam. Let's be real. Nick is happy Charlie is dead, but he knows
he has to play the PR game to continue to be in the spotlight.
Um, Nick would tweet that regardless of his personal feelings,
right? That that's not because he is doing it to be in the spotlight.
He does it because I go back and forth on how sincere I feel
like um Nick's faith is. Sometimes I feel like his faith is quite
performative and fake. Sometimes I think it's quite sincere.
But this is a part of being a like a religious person, right?
If you're a religious person, this has to be your takeaway because
you you have to above all things decry like violence like people,
right, of like nonviolent people. That's just the Christian thing
to do. So whether or not he's he's legitimate in that he's it's
the Christian ethos, right? Charlie died. God damn it. This is
not the way. I didn't just know him from our interviews and debates,
but I met his wonderful wife. This is beyond heartbreaking. Violence
is so stupid. He was a real person, a human being who just died
in front of our eyes. Tragic. Yeah, Charlie hated empathy. And
I like karma. Pour a bureau over his neck hole if you feel so
bad. God damn. I don't know. It's just like people just want
to be performatively like non-human. Uh if people are funny with
it, okay, that's what I'll say. I can actually
I promise you I can like let this go. I can let really stupid
comments go if they're funny. But none of these people actually
want to be funny, right? They just they're like spiteful, hateful
people who are just saying that they're spiteful and hateful.
Yeah. Like if you're funny enough, it's just that's the line,
right? Just be funny. I'm sure there's tweets about Charlie Kirk
dying that I could laugh at. I promise you I could laugh at them,
right? Like I like dark humor, especially in times of tragedy.
I would get it. But the problem is you can't really divine the
line on dark humor very well when you actually hate the person.
When you actually truly hate the person, you can't find the line
on that. You will just you'll come off as hateful. You will be
hateful. If you don't hate the person, you absolutely can like
figure out where the line is. You can you can like uh do something
that's I think pretty edgy and funny. Yeah, this is Sorry, I
did see this one. Will Charlie Kirk run for any government office?
That's rough.
Listen, markets are ruthless. Okay, markets are ruthless.
We know that.
We know it. We know it. This one was kind of funny. I'll determine
that. I I don't know the reference. I I don't know the reference.
Take those odds. Yeah. I Dude, so many people are just like,
"Yeah, I hate violence." Oh, right. We need to watch the Jesse
Waters thing. True, true. Jesse Waters is a Uhoh. Dink donk.
>> By the way, you should there's like a meta level of
analysis that happens here. And this is um Listen, proof that
you can be better than Arabs, okay? Proof as a as a white man
living in the white man's land, all of North America. I'm just
I'm around. But as somebody who lives in North America, prove
you can be better than those people in the Middle East. Understand
that all of these people, there will be extremists on both sides
of this who will point to the extremists on the other side and
go, "We have to fight these people." Right? That's how they want
to keep you pulled in and like hating everybody is they're going
to point to like Merrick and morons like Jesse Waters and they're
going to say, "Look, this is this is who the other people are."
And it's like, there are a lot of people who don't feel that
way. There are a lot of people who don't want any amount of political
violence, right? But don't don't be like like this is like when
Israel points to and goes, "Well, there's like terrorists over
there and they have genocidal intent." It's like, "Yeah, but
there's a whole bunch of other people over there who don't have
that." You see Merrick's post? Yeah, we saw Meritt's stupid posts.
Merrick is not representative of the left. Jesse Waters is not
representative of the right. Okay. Or at least the people who
vote. It's not representative of representative of the citizenry.
Could be a little more representative of pundits. 200,000 likes.
Not great. You know what? I like 200,000 likes, lav on the thought
leader of the next generation. Okay? The guy who actually knows
how to uh how to say what needs to be said. And nobody hated
Charlie Kirk more than this guy. Okay? Just be be like Nick,
okay? Even when you hate the other person, you understand that
like they have a family. They're a father. Uh it's it's a terrible
thing for kids to be able to see how their father's slain. That's
awful.
Be like be like Nick, okay? in this moment. Give us ID pole betting
odds. 30% groper, 40% lefty, 30% schizophrenic. Too hard to categorize
the others. Um,
let's see here. Check Sam Hides feed. I'll check Sam Heights,
but we need to watch the Jesse Waters thing. I was just going
to say that I think
I think it's going to be um like anti-ionist,
left or right-wing anti-ionism. So like some kind of anti-semitism,
anti-ionism. I think that's what it's going to be. I really do
cuz people forget that Charlie Kirk is like the biggest pro-Israel
propagandist. He's like putting so many people on the side of
Israel in America. So many young people. He was like the person
who was getting them on the side of Israel for like years and
years and years. So much so that and by the way anybody who says
that he's a he just debates people on campuses. Okay? Charlie
Kirk does not just debate people on campuses. All right? You
don't get the prayers from the literal prime minister of Israel
when you just debate people on campus. Okay? That's not what
happens. Not, by the way, not I'll never ever say no matter how
much of a of a Zionist shill Kirk was, still doesn't deserve
that. I don't think he deserved that at all. I don't think it's
okay that it happened. Right? But I'm saying that like this is
to me this is why it probably happened if I had to bet on something.
Okay? Could be Republican, could be uh leftist. I I don't know,
but I think it's somebody who very much disliked his organization
stance on Israel and possibly would have disliked I'm guessing
there's a small outside chance that it's like the people who
thought that him or other people were softening the Epstein blow,
right? Don't Don't forget, okay, don't forget what is it called?
Critical theory, okay? Don't forget CPT.
A lot of Republicans are still very about the Epstein stuff getting
covered up. All right. I wouldn't I wouldn't in terms of the
oddsm I wouldn't get
wouldn't get too doubtful of that. I think it could be very easily
that. Um let's see here.
It's a griper for sure.
I don't So I can't see it because I don't know if we've had violence
from gripers before. Gripers seem like um I just I think it's
like I do think it's like anti-griper ethos to become violent.
Evil Johnny Bravo. This is the trans person Dick is proposing.
We covered that already. But yeah, I know. I see you. I see you.
Oh, hold on. Oh.
Oh no.
I just got five messages like this. What did Veto say? I've been
a fan since I was 16. I'm 28 now. Listen to every show. I've
I've held off canceling my biggest problem in the universe Patreon
for your sake cuz you're great. But after today, I can't support
Veto any longer. Cancel and unfollowed that pig. It's time for
the show to end. I'll up my TDS subscription. Please kick Veto
the curb. You scum. I bought Superkiller. I was a [__]
Veto file on the Patreon. It's over. September is the month when
everything changed. That lying self-centered something, dude.
Veto was tweeting some dumb stuff. Okay. Veto was tweeting some
dumb stuff. Not good. Not good. Weren't Griers? Yeah, sorry.
Like, it's a Catholic. It's like a Catholic group. You're not
supposed to You're not supposed to kill people. Griers love state
violence. They might love state violence. They do not I don't
think any part of their ethos endorses like any kind of violence.
I guess you could say that a lot of about a lot of different
groups, but what a Veto tweet. Oh, Veto tweeted some dumb. Hold
on, let me go let me go to Veto's page. Veto is basically laughing
about it and going like, hold on, let me let me just look directly
because I don't want to misquote him. This one tweeted this and
said the American comeback
and it's like it's this, but it's like veto.
Hold on, let's look at the first reply. You know, this man died
in front of his family. Show a bit of respect. I think it's a
cool tour name. when Crowder was caught on table for verbally
abusing his pregnant wife. I canceled Mug Club and have never
watched him again. I've already So, this is Veto just kind of
laughing about it, right? Oh god, what is this? >> Say
it with me. Trans rights are human
>> Okay. Yeah, we just covered the merit stuff. Let's cover
Jesse Waters. Okay, I'm not going to I'm not going to read it.
I'm going to just listen. >> Trump gets hit in the ear.
Charlie gets shot dead. They came after Kavanaaugh with a rifle
to his neighborhood. They went after Musk's cars. They just shot
two. Oh, no. Not Musk's cars.
No.
>> Why don't you include that in there? Did he just not
have enough for his list? He wanted like the list, but he didn't
have enough for the list. So, he's like, "Yeah, they came off
Elon Musk's cars, guys." Oh, no. >> Outside the embassy.
Think about it. Scaliz got shot. >> Oh, hold on. >> Two
outside the embassy. Think about it. Scaliz got shot. Barely
survived. >> I'm trying to think. Oh, right. The Minnesota
people. Yes. So,
surely in this list we'll have the Minnesota politicians who
are getting shot. Surely >> it's happening. We got trans
shooters. We got riots in LA.
They are >> God, that trans shooters point is so dumb,
but it hits so good for these people, right? It hits so good
for all of them. The trans shooters point. It's so stupid. It's
so stupid. Well, sorry. It feels stupid to me. Maybe maybe there's
like enough of an uptick in the data for it not to be stupid.
I feel like there's not. But we'll see. I just I feel like I
don't know. >> They're at war with us. Whether we want
to accept it or not, they are at war with us. What are we going
to do about it? How much political violence are we going to tolerate?
And that's the question we're just going to have to ask ourselves.
Now, Charlie would want us to put as much pressure on the >> Sorry.
Um,
what I should say, Cy, is I think the trans stuff in a lot of
cases, especially when they become violent, I think that's often
downstream of like some existing mental illness, right? That
to me is it seems like that's the case. Okay. And I would say
that's like the primary problem.
And becoming trans is like a way of like self-medicating for
that kind of thing. And then probably when that doesn't work,
they find some other way. But like not by the way, I don't even
think that's broadly the experience. I think that is the experience
of people who end up like
themselves or doing violent acts in general, right? Is that you'll
see them try a lot of different extremist ideologies or extremist
extremist like acts. They'll take drugs. They'll they'll act
out in these ways cuz they're trying to fix something, right?
Intellad, I would just say probably if you look proportionate
populationwise,
maybe trans shooters are starting to become like an outlier in
some way. Possibly. possibly.
Let me let me back it up here. >> How much political violence
are we going to tolerate? And that's the question we're just
going to have to ask ourselves. Now, Charlie would want us to
put as much pressure on these people as possible. Dana nailed
it. This is unacceptable
and has to stop. And it has to stop now. And everybody's accountable.
And we're watching what they're saying on television. And who's
saying what? The politicians, the media, and all these rats out
there. This can never happen again. It ends now. Greg's right
again. This is a turning point. And we know which direction we're
going. >> Okay. Okay. Yeah. Shut the Oh, that's gross,
dude. The pun that's a poor taste. That pun is in poor taste.
Yeah, he just called for violence. Sorry, I'm reading a tweet
on the side. I need to watch it again. is unacceptable
and has to stop. And it has to stop now. And everybody's accountable.
And we're watching what they're saying on television. And who's
saying what? The politicians, the media, and all these rats out
there. >> This can never happen again. It ends now. Greg's
right again. This is a turning point. And we >> Dude, it's
it's so It's so stupid to go and do this. It's so dumb, honestly.
You should take the guy off the off the air for a couple weeks
or something. Like, as soon as you go and do this, it should
just be, "No, no, no. We don't do this. We just don't do it from
anyone. This guy's got such a massive platform with Fox News.
It's so stupid to go do this." Is it a pun or attempt at an homage?
It's both, maybe. Dude, nobody's going to wait for his uh Nobody's
waiting for his corpse to get cold. Okay, that corpse is warm.
It's useful to all of these people. They're going to take they're
going to take their piece and they're going to run in a direction.
They're going to try to use it for something, right? This is
so stupid.
But I'll I'll continue to say Jesse Waters is not not a good
depiction of like who the rightwing is in my opinion. Not at
all. This is R&D.
You could maybe say that. I'm sure there are people like people
on Twitter making the same point or hold on. Let's see what we're
going to next.
Okay. I need to I'll have to go to the Twitter, sorry, to the
Discord after this. In content suggestions, I'm looking for like
feedback or reactions to this that we want to rate. We want to
go through it. I was thinking about possibly maybe, just maybe,
okay, doing like a reaction tier list. Okay, we go to tier maker,
we make a reaction tier list with all the links, all the responses,
right? And we try to rate them. We'll see. Regardless of any
political beliefs you may have, I think it would be a it would
help a lot if we denounce acts of violence more often. That video
is horrible, no matter what side you're on. Awful.
Funny how people only denounce violence when it's convenient
for their side. Where was all where was all this moral clarity
when their crowd was doing the same thing? I don't need that.
Again, I can just act with my own principles. I can just act
with my own principles in general. And I see you got some good
reacts I saw on Queen. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I know. I know.
But it's the not so erodate stuff is funny because
she's been like so
she's been so attached to Destiny. It's just funny seeing the
two like the uh what do you call it? The divide there. Okay.
It's just very funny to me. Close tabs to the right. America
is an insanely violent nation. Charlie Kirk shooting is the 46th
school shooting thus this year thus far.
You called for violence against your political enemies before.
You have called for violence against your political enemies before.
Muhammad. Okay. Uh I do think it's weird to call it a school
shooting. I just call it Yeah. An assassination. It's clearly
an assassination. One target. This guy was not trying to do a
mass casualty event. This guy was clearly just going for this
alone.
This only. Hutch and Hassan are all you need. Riy, link the Hassan
time stamp. Link me Hassan. Hold on a second.
Link me the Hassan thing and let's get to that. Let's get to
it cuz I want to I want to watch I want to react to Hassan. Let's
check it out. Oh, only mute safer work opinion on this. Hold
on. Let's see it. Yeah. Oh, it's the same thing. Yeah, everybody
does the turning point thing is gay. Um, they're all gay. Only
mute. They all They all suck. They all suck. That's just the
way it is. There was a school shooting that took place just before
the assassination.
Oh, at this school or a different school? Okay, we're going to
watch the Hassan stuff. Maybe we'll watch the Hutch stuff. I'm
going to keep scrolling through some of these until I possibly
get like a time stamp. Dude, Elon Musk had some really dumb [__]
today. The left lectured us for the last decade about the dangers
of violence from the right for the assassination attempts of
President Trump to Brian Thompson, the healthcare CEO being murdered.
Now to Charlie Kirk, the danger was actually on the left. Uh,
hold on.
SDL SDL doing a little uh little cover for some murders here.
Hold on. Where's the SDL tweet? Every political assassination
in the US in the past 25 years until today has been perpetrated
by a conservative Portman Josh Shapiro are okay.
Okay. Uh Gretchen
Uh I don't know that this is uh really Wait, hold on. Why is
it number of deaths not including perpetrator Mike
Like do we not see how disingenuous this is when only Republicans
died cuz they were fat slobs who had heart attacks on January
6th? But it says five deaths Republican caused. I mean, technically,
I guess if you want to get really
>> Asmin Gold just tipped $5.
Yeah, I said I went on indefinite break yesterday because of
my dad's cancer. That was just to throw the trail in case I got
caught for this. >> Um, okay. Thank you, Asmin Gold. Jesus
Christ. Here's him just p head past just watching news where
he talks about Twitter. Wait, what? >> Kirk, it's horrific.
It's one of the most horrible things I've ever seen. He was a
great guy. He said he was incredible guy. Nobody like him. Dude,
that is a that is a crazy shot. We don't know. We don't know.
>> Imagine the spin if the shooter turns out to be Republican.
Um I mean it seems possible.
I don't know. I don't know if it will happen. It seems possible.
>> Exactly. Uh I mean that is the
this is the suspicion. I guess that's what the New York Times
reported as well. 200 yards. But it is a it's a crazy >> it's
not possible. Ain't a TA. Why do you think it's not possible?
It's obviously a lefty nut job. Why do you say that? Here's the
thing. To me, lefty nut jobs never have military training. Okay,
that guy fired a shot. He almost got away. That guy evaded police.
Like, he evaded capture right away. That guy had like a plan.
In general, I just think of lefties as like too useless to really
do that at all. >> He distance for a shot like that. Authorities
Oh, just in from AP. Authorities are still searching for the
suspect in the shooting death of Charlie Kirk. Mayor says that
>> a formal adviser he >> in Utah at a campus event
to the horror of the thousands who had gathered there. He was
in the middle of >> Yog America's Groer war. Yeah, that's
what I said. Rhinox. I said it was um or wait I didn't say that.
I said that earlier today. Uh while talking in like a totally
different place. Um
dude, Nick Nick Fentes is like just like rubbing, you know, he's
like doing this sweaty guy like he just dodged a bullet cuz they
did chase and harass Charlie Kirk. They're going after Charlie
Kirk forever. And he basically just like let up and was like,
I want to debate Charlie Kirk. Let me debate Charlie Kirk. Right.
He let up totally
and just in time. Okay. So it's not like an unhinged schizophrenic
groper who's doing this. Or at least he's not going to get the
blame in the same way. I think the reason people think it's a
lefty. So certainly like I could see it being a lefty over Israel.
I could see it being a righty over Israel. I could see it being
a righty over
uh what do you call it? >> Yeah. The the Israel Palestine
situation. Okay. We're right at this time right now. instability
every single it's like people who perhaps are most responsible
for setting up an an environment where uh violence and instability
is the norm for everyday Americans. Okay. People who have set
up an environment where >> ready that wants to No, I think
it would be the Epstein stuff. I think it would be like I think
they would probably think Charlie Kirk is like just general cover
for like the administration. There is just no solution to unlimited
gun violence every single day where parents send their children
to school and there's no guarantee of their safety and some
uh experience
exactly what the Republicans the fear and anger that the Republicans
are currently experiencing because they knew Charlie Kirk. Regular
people experience that
unfortunately all too all too frequently.
Okay. Meanwhile, while they're talking about toning down the
rhetoric of violence, Elon Musk, the owner of this,
dude, Elon Musk's a stupid, dude. Yeah, sorry. I didn't actually
get sufficiently soy about this tweet. Okay, the Elon Musk tweet
was actually moronic.
He is he is amplifying it. Not in the same way Jesse Waters is,
which is like super direct and super obvious. It's like a little
he takes a little of the edge off, right? Just a tiny bit. So,
for like the tiniest bit of plausible deniability site, took
no time like didn't even wait for the confirmation of Charlie
Ker's death to immediately go the left is the party of murder
two months ago
a psychopathic right-winger
a far-right evangelical Christian
had a hit list of numerous Democrat politicians he went into
the homes of Democrat politicians in the state of Minnesota and
he shot and killed two and he tried to kill more
Okay Yeah, that did happen to >> And these guys immediately
said, "Oh, he was a leftist. He was actually Tim Waltz's guy.
He was Tim Waltz's top guy." Made no sense. Tim Walt was literally
a part of the assassination hit list. And people still ran along
with that narrative. There's no confirmation of the shooters
ideological background or whatever.
>> Okay, I'm going to start looking at Sam Hides in the
background. Okay, none of that. But that doesn't stop these demons
from immediately saying, "Oh, it's the left that's doing this.
It's the left that's doing this. It must be a leftist that did
this." So spare me the about toning down the rhetoric when this
is the common meta. Okay, I'm going to take a quick look at Sam
Hyde's. Okay, I understand there's some uh some language on here
that we don't want. Do we I kind of want to leave the Twitch
running cuz we got a little traction on Twitch right now, but
I don't know if I want to scroll this with Twitch running. Pass
hit 220K today, guys. 220,000 viewers. It was crazy. Okay, I
don't know why he tweeted this out. Do you believe Derek Schovin
should be released? Yes, that's the repost before this. So, his
first response, "Pray for Charlie Kirk. Get a gun today if you
don't have one."
Okay, little little Vosch action there. Believe that's a Vosch
quote, right guys? If you if you want things to change, get a
gun. Ethan was so mad about Hassan's viewers. I There would be
a lot of people mad about Hassan's viewers. Okay,
these guys these guys get so angry about Hassan. They throw all
of these attacks at Hassan. Hassan immediately bounces up to
200,000 viewers. They're just like amplifying this guy's platform.
They're making it big. You don't want to read it on Twitch. Trust
me. Okay, guys. We're going to end the Twitch stream. All right.
Head over to kick kick.com/jok.
Head over there. Hop in. We're covering stuff over there. Okay.
I love you if you're on Twitch today. Love you if you're on Twitch.
But we uh we're going to go over to kick only. All right. Kick
only. See you in a minute. There's going to be a lot of other
stuff that'll be edgy today as well. So, we might as well just
get over to kick only right off the bat. Let's do it. Let's do
it. Okay.
What are we looking for? Verain link to time stamp. This is more
Oh, that's not it.
I think you just need to I need I think you need to click that
button off. Not for long periods of time, but like the second
you assume somebody's calling for violence, tap needs to be shut
off for a little bit, right?
So, these people know that if you're going to do that, you spend
the next month like without a paycheck. I need lowering the temperature
doesn't get clicks. Yes, I need the monetary incentive for people
to be unhinged to be eliminated. I want that monetary incentive
gone. Okay. Social media companies benefit from a bunch of this.
Hey, I think probably Coca-Cola doesn't want you advertising
their product on top of somebody saying you got to kill leftists.
You got to kill Republicans. They don't pro they probably don't
want that. I'm just throwing it out there seems like unlikely
to me. So I think I think when you're basically I think to be
honest I think just going like I don't care that that guy died.
I think that should be like I'm bordering on thinking that that
should just be 24 hours you're you you should learn to shut the
[__] up. won't ever happen until they do away with
platform protections. Maybe. Yeah, I guess because then if they're
they're moderating too hard, it's it gets used against them.
Yeah. The unfortunate thing is, see, this is why I like have
to think about it more. Even if you implement those rules, you'll
probably see it be used really one-sidedly, right? Like really
in a stupid one-sided way. So, it it like sucks. Has started
shooting yet? I dude, it's there's a lot of people like this.
Okay.
>> Mass shootings in America. I got another You know how
many mass shooters there have been in America in the last 10
years? A person asked. counting or not counting gang violence,"
Kirk responds right before he is shot. "That right there,
that right there is is America perfectly described."
Okay?
Because the
the the dark irony of this this sequence of events is that it
is that mentality that stops people from even seeking the truth
about how or seeking solutions on how we could stop gun violence
in this goddamn country. >> I just don't see. So, I think
they're going to find this guy and they're going to find out
that he has like some kind of training and that there's no reason
to believe he even had like an AR-15. Like, he might have just
had a standard. He could have had like a uh
like a well-sighted boltaction rifle, right? Probably not. Probably
something with like a little more balanced and gamed, but like
there's no reason to believe that he had like like there's no
he didn't need something for a mass casualty event. And I don't
think I believe it was I didn't hear more than one shot. Bones
nine. I believe I heard one shot and only one shot. So he was
clearly not going for a mass casualty event. If you're going
to legislate against mass casualty events, you wouldn't have
done anything here, right? If it was semi-automatic, why not
fire a second shot? I mean, to be honest, if he was if he was
cited after the shot and saw what happened, like I think he just
knows, right? Yeah, we we watched the video of the guy running
on the the the
roof as well. Yeah, the guy was running away. Dude, this was
like well planned. I think this is somebody that was like trained
to do this. Like that's why I would lean that's why I would personally
lean heavier rightwing than left wing. That's just my personal
opinion, right? is I feel like this person had some kind of training
like militarily trained or like maybe as a hobbyist and that
just tends to skew right-wing more. That would be my But by the
way, I don't I don't think that matters. Like I I don't I'm not
making like some claim about that. Just so we're clear. I just
say if I was betting money, that's what I would bet on. Like
it doesn't it doesn't matter to me if he was Republican. They're
um like no matter what, everybody needs to be lowering the temperature.
Doesn't matter to me if he's Republican or leftist or whatever.
It's everybody needs to bring the temperature down. Everybody.
Anyway,
sorry. Where were we going next? I was going to pull up this
other Hassan. This is a different part of his rant. Okay. >> Um,
there is a closeup.
>> There is a closer uh uh footage of Charlie Kart getting
shot in the >> This is way earlier today, by the way. I
don't know if he went live just to cover this, but
>> where you can click Oh, he's dead. Oh my god, he's definitely
dead. Oh my god. I can't believe I just saw that. >> This
is like every normal person's reaction, by the way. Like it's
it's like really bad.
Like you don't you don't see that kind of video. You see that
kind of video on like um what was it? What was the site that
you used to watch this stuff on? Not Livewire. It was um Live
Leak. This is like some Live Leak. Yeah. This is some live leak
[__] from back in the day, but it was with a famous
guy like that. It was crazy
and gross. Yeah. >> Oh my god. >> I think this is
a normal human reaction.
>> Oh my god. Oh, he definitely got shot in the neck. Oh
my god. Oh. Oh, yeah. No, I I that that footage that you do not
want to see that. You do not want to see that. You do not want
to see that. That footage that footage the close-up footage shows
very clearly immediately blood. I think this is like why I have
a hard time
like the cheap the cheap digs at this seem like really bad to
me is like you could see that and again I maybe I'm just like
a maybe I'm just like a with this stuff but I just think like
his kids have to exist in a world where that footage like exists
forever
like where they they see their dad die in like high definition.
I don't know. It's it's funny. >> Pouring out of his jugular.
He gets shot in the neck. blood pouring out of his jugular, like
an an unimaginable amount of blood pouring out of his jugular.
There is very very little chance that he uh survived that. I
don't know. I don't know if he did. Uh but uh I it doesn't seem
like it. Oh my god, that was [__] devastating. Holy
[__] I really I I don't know what to say. Oh my lord.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Holy [__] America is so absolutely [__]
Fox News is covering it now. >> So, not even 30. >> I
just want to point out that Hassan is like, "This is gross. This
is right. There's a Reddit post of someone being like, "Please
tell me he died." And then he was like, "Never mind. I saw the
footage. No one deserves that." Yeah. I think I think people
are pretty disconnected from just reading news. Right. This guy
loves political violence and terrorism. By the way, I just want
to point out
that the the the the
stark difference in the reactions. Okay, Hassan, how do I explain
this? Okay, Hassan just he has the human reaction. Okay, it's
the human reaction he's disturbed. He's he's up by this. Okay,
he's [__] up by this. I just want to skew this with
the reaction from other people who are like, wait, how is this
going to affect like my business opportunities? remind you the
people who are worried about their business opportunities, the
best case scenario for them is they get what Hassan also would
have lost. And clearly it's the furthest thing from his mind.
Clearly Hassan is not thinking, "Oh, I just lost my debate opportunity
with Charlie Kirk. That's really good content we're never going
to get." Now, that's not Hassan's first thought, right? Hassan's
first thought is, "Oh, [__] This is really like messed
up." Hassan does make a comment about it. Well, he's he might
comment on like, "Yeah, I was going to meet this guy again, right?"
Hassan debated the guy. Yeah, Hassan debated the guy >> minutes
ago. 29 minutes ago, he had posted
images of himself before this huge crowd at uh Utah Valley University
there outside of Provo. And he he said, "We're so back." You
could see there was enthusiasm. He was passing hats around. You
can watch him on video. This is just this was posted half an
hour ago uh of him doing that and greeting this crowd. He is
somebody that the Trump campaign, as Kristen was noting, utilized
very effectively to harness his leadership in
>> uh big news, guys. The person they caught is not the
person. The person they caught is not the person. They did not
catch the person. The subject they had has been questioned and
released. No, no, no, no, no. This is not the boomer. This is
a second guy. No, no, no. This is not the old guy. Tequila Sunset.
They got a guy after the old guy. They said the old guy was gone.
Then they got a different guy and said they got him. This was
like an hour ago. They said they got him. A different guy. Except
now it's like a a different different guy. Now it's not that
guy either. These two posts are the most embarrassing thing I've
seen from the FBI director. What the [__] are you
Were you thinking making an announcement like that? And the guy
they arrested had a plet gun. Oh, apparently they arrested a
guy with a plet gun. Damn. Okay. Oh, the old guy's docks. The
old guy. I I didn't think it was going to be the old guy, but
um they did say they had a different guy in custody and now apparently
nobody. I believe the governor might have also said they had
somebody in in custody, like a different person,
which I mean they did have somebody in custody technically, right?
No, that wasn't done with a pellet gun, guys. That's not what
we're saying. That was not done with a pellet gun. Stop.
Stop. Stop.
Cash Patel is kind of a total joke. conservative activist movement
again with young people, young men specifically. We've talked
about this a lot when we look back. Charlie Kirk is the heart
of that effort. They relied on on him and his organization a
lot for their ground game in a lot of the states around the country.
And so this is somebody who obviously has a huge voice inside
conservative American politics, a big Trump supporter, uh but
obviously now in this really unfortunate horrific experience
is going to be at the center of a conversation about political
violence I would imagine that we're going to be having uh in
the aftermath of this horrific event. >> Oh, certainly.
And there's a lot of reason to be concerned right now is we do
not know uh his status. We don't know how he's doing and we're
awaiting word certainly of that. as you mentioned, it says a
lot about where we are as a >> that this must be so weird
given that I'm sure a lot of the journalists saw the full footage
and they're like they're saying what like a lot of online commentators
won't say, right? Because I think you I think it's just a major
faux paw to to declare somebody dead before like people are like
for journalistic organizations to for them to declare him dead
before the family's notified even if you think he's dead, right?
But like, yeah, if you watch that close-up video, it's um it's
over. It's over. >> When it comes to violence and politics,
can you talk a little bit about what he was doing in Utah? He
was going to universities to speak to young people. >> Yeah.
And and organizing them and and again, that's why I was literally,
you can just bring it up from his Twitter page a little while
ago. You can see it's not just like sometimes >> Charlie
Clark was doing an event the one of the classic events that he
does like a change my mind style event at Utah at a campus on
Utah at UVU campus. He was sitting under a tent. One shot rings
out and immediately his jugular opens up and blood is just pouring
out of his neck. I I I saw it. I'm confirming it. I'm telling
you right now. Um there is a very very low likelihood of >> uh
a knife slash that spot can be in a minute. That was a high-caliber
rifle that went through his neck. Yeah. The thing is with a slash
you usually have like a clean cut that could be sewn back together
by a surgeon that can be pinched off that can be sewn back together.
With a gunshot I'm guessing you have like the obliteration of
that artery and there's nothing to put back together. Like it's
just like uh
there's there's just literally nothing to put back together there.
It's like done >> survival beyond that point. I I I mean
I don't know. I don't know what's happened. I I I I
don't It's not fire rally tweet. I'm guessing it's going to be
Let me predict. Let me predict the re tweet before I go look.
I'm guessing it's going to be some Charlie Kirk tweet and saying
that like Charlie Kirk didn't care so why should I? I'm just
guessing that's going to be I condemn all violence but someone
should tell him that. What is this? Tri clerk says gun deaths
unfortunately won't keep are ultimately worth it to keep second
amendment. That's not relevant.
Um let's see here. What is this?
What is this? Trier calls for his audience to post bail for the
Pelosi attacker. If some amazing patriot out there in San Francisco
or the Bay Area really wants to be a midterm hero, someone should
go bail this guy out. Bail him out and then go ask him some questions.
Can I see what he said? Can I see what he said? Where's the video?
I don't know what the video is. That's such a point. We keep
Yeah, I mean that's Bones dying. That's literally what Charlie
Kirk is saying at the beginning of the clip. At the beginning
of this clip, he says, "Yeah, like we we decide that the convenience
of cars, like the pos the pros of having cars are actually more
important than the offset like deaths that happen." And he makes
the same point about guns. He's like, "I think the ability to
defend oneself, to have your defense in your own hands, to have
like this uh internal locus of control with regards to your self-defense
that you don't have to rely on the cops in a bad situation. You
will be able to defend yourself. I think that the spirit of that
is worth it. Right. I think that's that's what Charlie Kirk's
author are arguing. That's what most right-wingers argue against.
See, >> I mean, I'm looking at politico.com.
I'm looking at the New York Times. I'm looking at all these.
>> It's ironic though, right? Guy dies by gun violence.
Yeah, but would it be preventable gun violence? That's that's
really the thing is like a ton of vi gun violence that happens
outside of the mass casualty events isn't even like gun violence
that most people argue against. Like I have I have no evidence
that any measure that they've proposed that is like a reasonable
measure that people want would have stopped this from happening.
Like there's just there's no reason to believe that this is um
like and if it was with a a rifle that you could have if it was
a rifle you could have legally. But if it was a rifle that like
is equivalent to one shot like some hunting rifle, I don't I
don't get it. Still pretty ironic though. I I guess so. I suppose.
Oh, hold on. Did we even finish this clip? I don't know if we
finished this clip. I mean, I'm looking at politico.com. I'm
looking at the New York Times. I'm looking at all these places
and there's a little bit of mention here. For example, Politico
says, "Top Republicans reject any link between GOP rhetoric and
Paul Pelosi assault." Of course, you should reject any link.
Why is the Republican party, why is the conservative movement
to blame
for gay schizophrenic nudists that are hemp makers breaking into
somebody's home or maybe not breaking into somebody's home? Why
are we to blame for that? Exactly. And why is he still in jail?
Why has he not been bailed out? By the way, if some if some amazing
patriot out there in San Francisco or the Bay Area wants to really
be a midterm hero, someone should I need to see like more of
how he talks about this stuff from this point. J, you argued
against not reducing the highway speed limit, but expect me to
care when a bus crashes into your living room. Is the tone. Yes.
Yes. Exactly. Evil Johnny Bravo. It's like, okay. Or like drunk
like a drunk driver hits you in that same situation, right? You
just ask Really? He's live right now. I don't have to ask Really.
We don't even have to I don't even necessarily want to talk about
it cuz I I just feel like it's uh I'm I'm just here to laugh
at the people who are going to do the the political spin like
on on day one over like Charlie Kirk dying. I'm here to laugh
at this stuff, right? Missing that his comments came on the backs
of other people. His comments came on the back of other people
being shot. Dying by being shot. Okay, that that can still be
true.
But I'm telling you right now that if you were to dig up the
corpse of Okay, you don't have to dig it up. If you were to commune
with Charlie Kirk on the other side and say, "Now you got shot
by somebody, should we have restrictions on 2A?" He would say
no. He would obviously say no. We all know that he would say
no. That's cap. That's not cap. You have to understand people
believe this. Dude,
if you got killed by a black guy and you believe that slavery
was bad and somebody came to you, they communed with you in the
afterlife and they go, "Yeah, well, if these people were slaves,
that guy wouldn't have been able to kill you, right?" Isn't that
ironic that you argued against slavery and a black guy killed
you? Isn't that ironic?
No. No. Obviously, there's a principle there. I don't I literally
don't understand how people don't get that. It's so easy to understand
this. Surely this fascist propagandist would be willing to die
for his principles. Well, he did. Whether he's willing to or
not, he did. By the way, I believe fascists most of the time
pretty committed to the idea of like owning weapons. There's
no second amendment principle. What? What do you mean there is
no second amendment principle? What? The ability to have your
defense in your own hands is the Second Amendment principle.
That you live a different kind of life if you aren't relying
on somebody else to defend you at all times. That having that
ability, whether or not you even are capable of actually wielding
it, that having that ability is inherently good and something
you should be able to have. that nobody should be able to take
your right to defend yourself away from you. That is a that is
literally a principle.
How do you not understand that? What do you mean there's no second
amendment principle? What zezy sidewalk chalk says? I understand
what you're saying. I just think it's wild to assume he would
be like, "Yes, I did get shot in the jugular. Yes, I do love
2A. Giga Chad, goodbye wife and kid." One, there's no reason
to think that 2A even if it was restricted or sorry, restrictions
on 2A would have protected him from this, right? a lone a lone
val lone wolf shooter like this that can that's somebody who's
motivated to get you killed that can come out in so many ways.
I don't think there's a significant way to protect you from that,
right? This is not the kind of thing that you want gun legislation
for mass casualty events, right? Where it's just somebody going
to a place and kill a bunch of people. You want legislation against
that. You want legislation against like gang violence that goes
off in cities that's like perpetrated entirely with pistols.
You don't you're not going to ever legislate against a lone wolf
shooter who is going to plan out meticulously kill you. You 2A
won't protect you from that. Nothing will protect you from that.
But yeah, people just want to make those points right now cuz
they're stupid, which is fine. Just we could be I don't even
I don't even like argue these points often. I'm sure they're
like good arguments from the other side. I'm just saying that
right now it just seems like stupid to me to argue that you could
legislate out of this. I just don't see it. >> It's the
most insane thing I've ever seen. The reason why I say most Multiple
people bring bring up Shinszo AB right now. Yeah, exactly right.
Japan the most insane gun control laws. If there's a if there's
a determined political assassin, they will be able to get to
you in like a lot of different ways. You can't have a society
that's like free, that feels totally free and and high-profile
individuals who feel free, who feel like they can intermingle
with society and not have like possible political
>> His jugular is because I've never seen so much blood
pour out of someone's neck in real time in like a moment's notice
before. It just it just completely gushes out. >> Wait,
ZZ sidewalk shock. I understand. Do you have to join the Discord
to like be proven that you're dumb on this? He What is he talking
about in the case where he says we need to accept some shootings
tab 2A? He is talking in my opinion about mass casualty events,
right? Is it not often mass shootings he's addressing there?
School shootings.
And he's saying it's important to me, but by the way, he does
stand by that, I think, right? That having like multiple guns,
having like AR-15s and that is something that should be your
constitutional right. That's very different from the kind of
thing we're talking about. Like what happened to him? Hold on.
Wait, I did not see this. Craziest editor's note ever. Editors
note. This story was published on September 8th. Jezebel condemns
the shooting of Charlie Kirk in the strongest possible terms.
We do not endorse, encourage, or excuse political violence of
any kind. We paid some Etsy wishes wishes to curse Charlie Kirk.
No way. Okay, that's
that's up. That That's funny. That's up. Oh my god. Somebody
get me, dude. Don't let Donald Trump see this. Okay, these people
are about to have like $50 million contracts taken out by the
Department of Homeland Security right now. Do not let Donald
Trump see this. September 8th. September 8th. If the farright
misogynist with a bad haircut wants to villainize independent
women, Jezebel is more than happy to be the hag of his nightmares.
Jesus. Oh boy. This is why you don't cross Zena. True. That's
wild. That's some wild stuff. Charlie Kirk assassin at America's
turning point. No, not you. Potentially criminal. No, don't do
the pun. Potentially criminal. No. No. You guys feel like political.
Hold on. Oh, sorry. You're talking about the governor's thing.
I don't know if I'm going to watch the governor's thing. It seems
and maybe maybe we'll go back to it. Do not watch the video.
If you have not seen the video, do not like the reason why I
watched it is because I wanted to see uh the reason why I watched
it is because I had to confirm whether or not this was a real
incident. I'm telling you, avoid it. It is one of the most [__]
up things you could possibly see. There is one video that uh
there was one video that was shot from afar that uh that basically
uh shows you his uh his head cracking back after you hear the
shots being uh after you hear the one shot fired. Um and then
the camera pans away. There is another video from inside of the
crowd, uh, a closer up video that is circulating online right
now where you literally see
where you just straight up see his >> This is This is how
you know Hassan's traumatized, okay? Cuz he keeps saying the
same thing. >> Jugular gush out uh after the after the
moment of impact. >> It's like the eighth time he said
this now. He watched it and he just keeps like replaying it in
his head. >> That second video is that second video, the
close-up video is from like 15 feet away. And I mean, look, I
I I cover I cover Israel genocide every day. I see I see charred
children. Um
why is he just brings it up out of nowhere? It's just like every
single time. Can we get We need some clock memes. Would you look
at the time? Israel Palestine. Israel Palestine. Israel Palestine.
Right. Every every every
single entry on the clock is Israel Palestine. I see I see children
carrying their their dead parents in in trash bags uh to the
hospital every day. It still is a little different
at least from my perspective I think because I you know this
is a person who uh does what I do but you know on the opposing
side I was supposed to debate him at Dartmouth University 15
days from now in a public event in a public setting. I go out
to public settings like this all the time. So, there's a there's
a level of
uh uh in in in that regard because of because of the nature of
of of what I >> He's still he's still rattled. No, Dreadmaster
I think I think he knows Charlie personally to some extent, right?
Like he debated Charlie when he was on TYT I want to say like
5 years ago, 6 years ago, like met him directly and they debated
live, didn't they? Wait, am I thinking about Bosch? No, Hassan
and Hassan and Charlie debated, didn't they? 2016. Okay. Yeah.
2018. >> I mean, look, I I have a policy of not living
in fear and uh you know, I I But we'll see. We'll I might have
to reconfigure certain things. This is This is insane. I never
thought I would see something like this. >> Rifle, was
it a handgun? >> But I guess if there's one country where
something like this could happen, it's this one. It's also notable
that he hosts as part of many of the events that he has these
debates with folks that come, college students and and others
who come as part of a crowd and and he hosts debates with them
at close proximity. We don't know that that's exactly what happened
here, but it is notable given what you were just describing,
Chief Ramsey, as the setting for the >> I'm going to I'm
going to flick it over to Dean really quickly. Okay, we got a
Dean Withers video update. Here's my thoughts on Charlie Kirk's
death. >> Kirk is dead. We got our We got our Instagram
filters fired up for the selfie video. We're mewing. Okay, we're
mewing hard into the camera. Now, let's see what's what's Dean's
opinion. Okay, >> he got shot at an event that he was hosting
in Utah. And I am sad, distraught. In fact, I just cried on my
live stream in front of 250,000 people. My goal in this >> Oh,
that's probably true. I just Sorry. It's just such a weird thing.
It's a weird thing to say after with a straight face. Yeah, it's
a bit of a flex and he says it with like a total totally straight
face
>> video is to tell you why. >> And Parker talked
about it in much more detail. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. >> Like
mass on a live. >> Hold on. Actually, yes. Let's Let's
check it out. Okay. Charlie Kirk and Parker. Let's check out
what they're >> And you know, we just ran. We didn't want
to get in the cross. Holy. It's just like the fact that like
>> which is here in about a week.
>> I'll be real. I'm scanning for Dean crying. That's what
I'm doing right now. This is after
>> And then just >> He's going to cry when he sees
the video up close and then I'm going to be like, "Dude, I almost
I I swear to God. I was in the grocery store and I was like a
little bit I was like a little bit.
It's [__] up to see it. It's actually [__]
up to see it. I'm not joking." Okay, I'll go back to Parker in
just a second. Give me a sec. >> How how he is doing. Still
no words.
Um, I'm also going to go ahead and quickly uh talk or send a
message to Parker. So, if if you're curious, Parker was there.
Um, I want to make sure that he's okay. I'm going to go and shoot
him a message. By the way, I I still just like wanted to be clear
that like it's been
an hour, an hour and 20 minutes since he was shot and, you know,
had all of the blood gushing out of his neck and he's still alive,
which is great. Which is a miracle. >> Oh god. Are we going
to watch him like click on something and it's going to be like
Charlie Kirk is dead? >> A godamn miracle. I'm hearing
other reports that he might be in surgery. >> And then
also somebody in my YouTube chat brings up a good point because
I was just criticizing the lady for smiling in that clip. It
very well just could be a couple ticks over. Very fair. Uh there's
a handful of like independent journalists that are saying he
is dead
>> from a reliable >> uh newsfeed. I mean >> wait
to hear from a reliable place. He's going to pull up the Trump
Truth Social, isn't he? >> That's a reliable place right
now. >> Just confirmed two minutes got Trump on um Truth
Social.
>> Doesn't deserve that, man. Him and his family. They
don't deserve that. >> That's true. >> His kids.
His kids don't his kids don't deserve that, man. >> Oh,
it's the same thing that caught me. Yeah. I think the the [__]
up thing is um Yeah. I just I feel like it's to me it's weird
to do this on stream necessarily, but whatever. Whatever. >> His
wife His wife and children were in attendance, dude. Imagine
>> Yeah, they were. Okay, so he's actually he's also saying
this. They were in attend. Yeah, it's like, >> you know,
imagine being a 12-year-old,
you know, watching your dad.
>> [__] I Nobody Nobody deserves that. Not
even Charlie Kirk. Nobody deserves that. >> Okay, that's
a little [__] up. Nobody deserves that. Not even
Not even Charlie Kirk. Okay, nobody deserves that. Yeah, I pulled
this tweet up earlier. Evil Johnny Bravo ret
>> I just think it's kind of irresponsible. Like more than
kind of insanely irresponsible of him. like ludicrously
>> Honestly,
as far as like Dean goes, what I expected here was for him to
like think about what this means for him and a bunch of other
like insane
like totally insane that he would say. And I think actually Dean
did a good job here. Dean is saying some good stuff. So, you
know what? Big ups. Big ups. I'm going to go back to the beginning.
Apparently Parker is upset here at the beginning.
And Parker, like I said, man, if if if you need some time, >> he's
definitely talking him down, >> right? And and I said this
earlier and I I I'll say it again now. I I want everybody to
keep in mind that
you should feel the exact same way. Okay,
if you're sitting at home,
>> I can't
hold on. >> I just had the news. I'm on my way to pick
up my new Robins.
>> Okay. Thank you very much, Batman. That's very weird,
but Robin was an orphan. These kids aren't orphaned, but thank
you for the five. Appreciate it, buddy. Oh, I didn't have my
subs reset, did I? This stream. Oops. My bad. Uh, I will reset
right now, guys. Guys, if you like the uh if you like the content,
go ahead and throw me a a sub. Throw me a gift. Sorry, throw
me a sub, you know, sub individually. Gift subs on kick. Buy
a TTS message. All right. I'm trying to I'm trying to do this
while I'm trying to reset things while I talk. My brain don't
work so good. I can't multitask like that. Guys, go ahead and
sub, donate, add more time to the stream. We are doing what?
Stream hours plus two 6010 and this
play on this. >> You're cheering it on. You're happy. You
wanted this. You're wrong. Okay. >> you you were wrong.
And if Brett Cross coming up here earlier, of course, now if
you're on YouTube, you didn't get to see this. Uh we've been
live over on TikTok for about for around an hour now. Brett Cross,
who's the father of a child that died at the Ovade school shooting.
He joined us for a little bit. He He spoke. He talked. And that's
exactly what he said, too. All right.
You You can't cheer gun violence on. You can't
>> Oh, let's go. Bob Rub, thank for the 10 gifted. That's
automatically two hours on the stream. Thank you very much, Bob
Rub. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. a father of two young children
possibly dying on even if you really don't like that father you
know um for the last year or so I have been the enemy of Charlie
Kirk right you know showing up to his event at Texas&M
trying to debate him talking to him on Jubilee
making videos saying that he's running from me you etc and here
I am making myself So very clear here.
I completely
110%
condemn what happened to Charlie today. It is disgusting.
It is it is dystopian. It is wrong. Um and it makes me sick to
think about the state of the country. And if you disagree with
that, there's now a line. >> God, there's just so many
people who are just making the correct call on this. Yeah, it's
just there's so many human beings out here on the internet >> between
you and me and I said this earlier and I just really want to
repeat it now with 50,000 people in the stream. >> I'm
going to real quick just say bub rub again. Thank you for the
10 gifted massive. Really appreciate it, dude. >> Don't
make this an issue of right versus left. Please don't don't make
this an issue of right versus left. Okay? Right? Because inevitably
if that line that separates the people that condemn this to the
people that celebrate this falls in between the right and the
left
then then I will agree with the right on this issue right and
I >> oh this guy's this guy's like all the way over in
the correct lane like hey if you're going to make this about
like oh you know I can't condemn violence until something like
no I'll just agree with the right you you I'll just separate
entirely you oh my god
How does Dean keep winning? >> I don't want to do that.
So, don't make that line fall in between the parties.
Okay. It shouldn't be right versus left. >> Uh, electrical
run 316.
Yes. And people on the left will do it, too. People on the left
will do the same thing. Don't focus on the extremists from the
other side. Focus on the broad basis of opinion on the other
side. Focus on the people who aren't unhinged. And know that
the unhinged people, bad things will happen. The unhinged people
will try to spin that against you. try to spin it so that like
their side attacks you or your side attacks them, whoever the
unhinged people are, wherever they are, right? It's just extremist.
Don't let extremist fighting extremists turn you into an extremist.
It's so stupid. >> It should be humanity versus inhumity.
Condemn gun violence.
We need to end gun
regardless of who it happened to. >> You're kind of a [__]
though. If I were there and the gunshots were fired around me,
I would have stood in front of my girlfriend. Okay, you're kind
of a [__] I just think it's like that's real easy
from the back row, okay? From the bleachers. People can just
like overlook that. I just don't get it, dude. Like, what the
is wrong with people? I don't get it. And the reason why I feel
such a need to go on live stream and do this is because I'm literally
it's making me crash out. Why? Why was I getting comments of
people on my post, >> bro? I saw this guy die and I thought
I was going to die and now I'm crashing out, guys. I'm I'm just
crashing out. They said I shouldn't stream about this, but I'm
crashing out. Okay, I don't Hundreds of
I I think this is like sincere. It seems like kind of performative
to me cuz he's using the language, but I think it's actually
>> Likes. Hundreds of likes of people saying that of people
like literally liking like that instead of worrying if I'm okay,
>> I don't understand that. Or worrying if other people
are okay. Like genuinely, what the [__] is wrong?
>> Worrying that everyone is okay. wanting to end gun violence
and condemning gun violence, right? And I mean, this is this
is just kind of like a further explanation on like why I said
what I said earlier. You know, Charlie Kirk wasn't the only individual
impacted, right? That should be enough.
Okay, we found the lefty part of the conversation.
Um,
listen, we have to stop gun violence cuz it wasn't just Charlie
Kirk who was traumatized. Everybody who watched him bleed out
in front of his family was also traumatized and you need to think
about them right now.
>> That should be enough to completely condemn it. >> That
should be enough. A father, regardless of what their thoughts
are of two young children getting shot in the neck and having
blood gush out of it. That should be more than enough to condemn
it, right? But consider everyone there. Consider Parker, bro.
consider, you know, my other friends that are >> this is
a good conversation if you just give it like like this is so
early on where he's like consider Parker. I'm just It's just
a little It's so early on that like they don't even know Charlie's
dead yet. They don't find Charlie's find out Charlie's dead for
like another hour on this stream. I don't know. I just >> on
campus that [__] like I had some other friends there.
They're calling me. >> I've not seen the Jackson Hlewig
tweet. Link it now. Um, consider everyone there. They don't know
who that bullet was going to. Maybe in in the in the in the heat
of the moment, what if it was going towards them? What if it
was a mass shooting towards the students? What if they were about
to unload and try to take everybody out? the the commotion in
in that fearing for your own life and not knowing what the hell
is happening. >> We had a HKLE tweet. >> That is
a scary traumatic
like lifealtering thing to go through. >> Let me take a
look. We had a HKL tweet. Hkle Hinkle. He used to be an Israeli
loyal Israel loyalist. He feared Israel would kill him. He started
mildly criticizing Israel. He said Epstein was mad. He let anti-Zionists
speak at his events. Zionist media started attacking him. Someone
shot his jugular 200 yards away. Netanyahu tweets within minutes.
Paty gets arrested and acts guilty. Assassin escapes without
a trace. Netanyahu tweets longer message. Something tells me
they're not going to give us the truth about who killed Charlie
Kirk. Okay, while I disagree with this, this is kind of what
I like if I were to be conspiratorial, right, and to just say
like my intrusive thoughts out loud, this would be like my intrusive
thoughts would be something along these lines, right? Where like
he was sort of slowly drifting to like letting people criticize
Israel at TPUSA events. Maybe not the rest of it. Yeah, we must
all pray for Charlie Kirk. Who is being who is being shot? Great
guy from top to bottom. God bless him. Praying for Charlie Kirk.
Oh boy. Oh boy. At the same time. At the same time.
No way. At the same time. That's crazy, guys. That's crazy. Who
the [__] has intrusive thoughts about Israel? Uh
when you see a guy who's like the most prolific pro-Israel propagandist
in America get shot, you might have some thoughts about Israel.
If you're like informed on politics at all, Dinglingus and know
who Charlie Kirk is and know what his organization's done to
push like pro-Israel rhetoric, pro proionist rhetoric in the
United States, you probably immediately have thoughts about Israel
when he gets shot. If you think about politics, sorry, immediately
once you start considering political ramifications over human
ones. Oh, shooter caught. No, this is this is a incorrect tweet.
This is incorrect.
Oh, and technical will update. Subject has been interrogated
and released. Shooter is presum shooter is presumably still at
large. More. Yeah. So Cash Patel
prolific muddying the waters all day and Zandy got away. Well,
I don't know if he got away yet, but it was just crazy to say
you got him and then nothing else. Dude, I got to I got to go
through the lab stuff really quickly cuz she I think she had
a good tweet like immediately. Oh, never mind. No, she didn't.
She had some weird tweets. Okay. If you commit an act of violence
or terror, your entire living family should be rounded up and
punished with you. It would be it should be a showing of what
America thinks of senseless political violence. The answer to
violence is more violence. Hm. You are I just think what if I
just hated my family? It's just like a weird weird proposition
in general. I This is like It's amazing that it's like dude,
people are attacking each other along partisan lines. They're
saying the dumbest things along partisan lines and then Lav just
comes in and says something dumb that's not partisan aligned
at all. She just says something that's like dumb on its own.
It's just flatout dumb. Wow. Uh and then she had one more tweet
that I wanted to cover. It was just liberals are laughing and
cheering about a man dying brutally in front of his wife and
children. These people cannot be reasoned with. There will be
no unity in America as we are. America is a ghost. It's like
I I would say this is just more like piling on to the same kind
of stuff. It sucks. I would just laugh at them. Point out how
they don't represent the majority. It's stupid. These have to
be uh probably not probably sincere. Oh, I do want to watch Dean's
like compact statement on uh on Charlie here. >> He got
shot at an event that he was hosting in Utah. And I am sad, distressed.
In fact, I just cried on my live stream in front of 250,000 people.
My goal in this video is to tell you why I feel this way. If
you want to end gun violence, it is something that you can never
celebrate. It is always disgusting, always vile, and always abhorentt.
It should come as no shock to >> You want to end this is
like the same uh this is the same thing. I just cried alive.
Yeah, we watched him actually >> I think Charlie Kirk was
a bad person. I've made that very clear over the last year. But
does that mean I think he deserves to lose his life? No. Does
that mean I think his two young children, who were in attendance
at the event where he was shot, deserve to watch their father
die? No. Does that mean I think they deserve to grow up without
him? No. Does that mean I think that his wife, who was also there,
deserved to lose her husband?
No.
And honestly, if you answered yes to any of those questions,
there's a very clear line drawn between me and you. I don't want
your support, and I don't support you either. >> We as
a collective need to end gun violence. And if that phrase is
a negotiable for you, I believe that you're in the wrong.
>> I I hate the political leanies take on this though because
it's like it's still pretty partisan in my opinion. Like he's
saying
he's saying, "Oh, we have to end gun violence." It's like we
have to control restrict guns. And it's like, dude, just say
it's bad. You could just say it's bad. My thoughts and prayers
go out to Charlie Kirk's friends, family, children, loved ones,
as well as every single person in attendance at his event today
in Utah. >> Let's see here.
Uh, Elizabeth Warren.
>> Elizabeth Warren of people who say Dems need to tone
down their rhetoric. Oh, please. Why don't you start with the
president of the United States and every ugly meme he's posted
in every ugly word. Yeah, I'd say Trump is the >> Oh, please.
>> I'm good with that. >> Right. Why don't you start
with the president of the United States?
Right. and every ugly meme he has posted and every ugly word.
>> Yeah, I would say I think it starts with Trump. I think
you could still just say like,
you know, I I don't think this is indicative of her take where
she's like, I condemn political violence. I'm sure she's got
that take, right? She can give that standalone, but when it's
like, oh, do Dems need to like tone down their rhetoric? I don't
I don't think Dem rhetoric is broadly violent, right? I don't
believe so.
Doesn't seem to be to me. All right, we keep we keep looking.
We keep looking. We keep looking. Yeah. I But I think that's
like clipped in a way that makes it a little disingenuous,
>> I would want to see more of this interview. I don't
believe this would be the only thing she said just cuz she's
like a fairly savvy political operative, right? That seems a
little clip chimp to me to just be like her saying no, no, no,
start with the president of the United States. See, Nancy may
say Dems need to take accountability for this. But when asked
a second later if Republic should take accountability for Minnesota,
she says what the no. But that sounds hypocritical and let's
keep uh let's keep looking. Dude, I I I thought this one was
particularly bad. This is war.
Okay, libs of Tik Tok. Okay, libs of Tik Tok. Okay, dude. Okay,
dude. Oh, we got a Oh, we got a broader thing here. Thank you.
Appreciate this. >> Just war and my heart goes out to his
family, to his friends,
but just cannot be a country that turns to violence when we disagree.
Oh, so there's like the actual take. There's the obvious one.
>> What can Congress do about it, Senator? >> One
thing Congress can do is gun safety. And every time there's a
Republicans say this is not the time to talk about gun safety
and yet we have to as a nation we >> So she did she did
listen. She followed follow JTO's rules for responsible political
activism. Okay? Never forget guys. Okay? First,
Charlie Kirk was a husband and father. This is unacceptable.
My thoughts and prayers go out to his family. Now, let's get
back to what's important. I need to use his death to push my
political agenda. We need gun laws. We need legislation. We need
gun control now. But she followed the rules. Okay. She was a
human first and then she followed the rules. So, w
huge. Wasn't she asked about guns?
She asked about legislation. Yes. She says when this happens
and she talks about mass casualty events or or gun violence,
right? and she says Republicans never want to talk about it.
She's now pushing the political agenda, but she was at least
the human first. >> More gun deaths
than most other nations and we don't keep our children, our friends,
our neighbors safe by just putting ordinary gun safety rules
in place. You know, I just want to say this coming from Massachusetts.
If the rest of the country would just follow the rules we follow
in Massachusetts,
we could reduce fatalities all over this
Uh, isn't Massachusetts like one of the richest states in the
union? Mass is like one of the richest states, right? I'll just
say violence in my from what I've seen violence seems to track
with poverty pretty closely. You've got like absolute like ghettos
in places like LA, like in Baltimore, like in Chicago where gang
violence is like all of the gun violence. And that's a totally
different problem to solve. And you think it like solves any
of this stuff and it doesn't. But this is like a ma this is like
a statistically illiterate take on solving gun violence, right?
Oh, if we just follow the Massachusetts program, we'll all be
fine. You have to be statistically illiterate to think that this
is a thing that solves the gun violence statistics as they are.
So she talks about how we have more gun deaths in the United
States than anywhere else in the world. and she ignores the biggest
causes of gun deaths. And she talks about other stuff like if
you had more laws on legal gun owners, well, like just like Massachusetts,
then we'd all be fine. when when a huge portion of gun homicides
are committed with illegal
>> and plenty of people who are hunters and who use guns
for sport still have lots of activities in Massachusetts
but at least we make it a little tougher to use guns for harming
other human beings. What do you say to people who are saying
the Democrats need to lower the temperature talking about things
and you >> right? Why don't you start with the president
of the United States? >> This is like I just think what
you should do is you I don't even mind if you say Trump is like
the impetus for this. Trump has raised the temperature. We're
following suit, but we should all lower. I think you should say
everyone should lower. We need the other side to lower. We need
our side to lower. Right. And you could say I still think Trump
is the biggest pusher of this. I just think this this is the
exact problem Republicans have. And maybe maybe you just never
get rid of it. I don't know. Maybe you just need civil war. I
don't know. Seems like that's the option. If you if you're the
side that's like, I won't denounce violence unless they denounce
violence. Then just say you want civil war, right? Don't be a
[__] or sorry, don't be half a [__] Be
the whole [__] Just say you want civil war. That's
all you got to do. Just say you want civil war, dog. >> Right.
and every ugly meme he has posted and every ugly word.
Uh he is the leader of this issue. And I think that when
he's posting things like he did just a couple of days ago, trying
to show an entire city on fire and a reference to helicopters
in in effect throwing people out of helicopters and showing himself
as some kind of big chest beating uh a
>> We penino posting now. Is that what we're doing? The
president is the president of the United States Pinochete posting.
Did I miss that? Did I miss Did I miss it? I missed the pino
fandom from Donald Trump. >> Uh then I just don't want
to hear this from the Republicans. Do you think >> Oh,
right. I did have the UN America official statement here somewhere.
I did I did have it. There it is. This is our official statement
from National Ground Game and the America Tour. Rest in peace,
Charlie Kirk. Uh the America Tour creators, organizers, and staff
are disturbed by the assassination of Charlie Kirk. The entire
mission of National Ground Game and the UN America Tour is to
have good faith debates with our political opponents. We were
really excited to meet with Charlie Kirk for a scheduled debate
a week from Sunday and are devastated by this outcome. Oh, wait.
Were they actually Hold on. They were going to have a scheduled
debate. Was Destiny debating Charlie Kirk? I didn't know about
that. Charlie was a husband, a son, and a father who loved his
country. Even though we disagreed with his political philosophy,
we respected the hard work it took to build TPUSA. As our founder
stated on CNN, "Unfortunately, one of the UFA debaters was debating
Charlie when this happened and had to witness this horrifying
traumatic event." Because of this, we are asking that people
respect both our creators and our staff's privacy while we grieve.
At this time, we have canceled all events until further notice.
We are keeping Charlie's family, friends, and staff in our prayers,
and we'll be there for them if and when they're ready to reach
out. We wholeheartedly condemn any and all political violence.
Like that post. That's a good post. That's a good statement.
Now, I think this is a really [__] weird statement,
though. And I will point out, okay, the the total lack of alignment
between the headliner of your tour events and your statements
is weird. It's weird to me.
Okay. It's just weird. Yeah. You You can't have a headliner for
your events that is going to take the tack that they do and then
say, "We condemn all of this. It's just all bad. Like, this is
really up." And then the guy who's headlining your events is
like, "You're a whole you're a if you do this." Trump just made
a video. We'll check it out. We'll finish we'll finish Liz Warren
first though. >> On both sides have a role though in trying
to turn the rhetoric down. >> I think what we have to say
is a violence is not the answer and we are willing to take steps
so that violence in this country is not so legal. Do we have
a single Republican who will stand up and join us following the
school shooting out in Denver? Uh, at the same time, school shootings
happen every single day. They have become common place in this
country. It's hard now to actually get attention when someone
has been mowed down with a gun. And Congress could change that
and should change >> I just asked Senator G. >> One
a day. one a day >> that same question before you and he
said you Congress can't change the heart of a man >> to
my great >> you can change a Trump statement coming up
in just a moment >> in their hands and the likelihood that
they will be able to another person or to kill themselves
goes up if they have a lethal weapon just those are the facts
and Republicans want to turn their backs on that because it is
more politically expedient but they are not making anybody safer
>> a lot of People are saying that political violence has
no place in our country, but it clearly does have some place
in our country. >> Fact of life now. >> It's a fact.
Is it just a fact of life now that there's >> I don't want
it to be a fact of life. And that's what we have to keep. We
have to keep saying no violence, but we also need to back it
up with actions and >> Yeah. I really hate the people who
are like, "Guys, this is just a new normal now." No, it's not.
You're one of the people who engages in this and you call it
a new normal. Shut the up. You don't get to say it's the new
normal. I like the old normal. I think a lot more people like
the old normal >> it up with actions means just taking
some modest steps for gun safety. And remember here most of America
agrees with us on modest steps on gun safety on things like background
checks. This is what America wants to do to protect our children.
And yet >> wasn't the old normal more political violence?
Um, I can't think of the last time a like influencer was shot
like this was doing like campus events. I don't know if it got
there. Yeah, we've got the Trump statement. American
>> bends a knee to a gun industry
that can >> uh how can you talk about solutions right now
if we don't have a shooter? So, you could talk generally about
like what what you think the solutions are to gun violence. I
just think from all indications, I don't think a lot of the proposed
legislation would work. I support a lot of proposed legislation,
right? like the background check stuff, not not having like loopholes
around background checks, um red flag laws, [__]
like that where they can start like temporarily doing things.
But the problem is you need more like uh you need actual judges
to go and like make sure that if you red flag somebody that they're
looked into immediately or investigators or whatever. That's
the problem is you you need to spend the money to pay those people
to go and investigate those things. You can't have somebody red
flagged and they sit there without their Second Amendment right
for 6 months. That's not possible. continues to make money by
stirring everyone up and making sure that everyone has access
to every possible lethal weapon. And that puts all of us at risk.
It puts our children at risk. It puts leaders at risk. And that's
a real mistake for our >> Senator Warren, do you feel safe
given all of this violence? >> How can anybody feel safe
today? I I worry when I send my grandchildren off to school.
Who doesn't? any education on guns like how we do with cars and
getting a driver's license. That's fine, Kuryoko. But that only
stops people who are going to use guns for legal purposes, right?
That's all it does. Yeah, licenses keep um keep people from driving
without a license sometimes. But if there's somebody who's just
hellbent on getting somewhere, guess what? The fact that they
don't have a license, they still get in that car and they drive.
Those things, they only stop people from uh like they don't really
help. That should be one measure, but it doesn't help with this
kind of gun violence. It never helps with this kind of gun violence.
You can do it and it's fine, but it doesn't help with this kind
of gun violence like at all. The reason there isn't this kind
of gun violence where they have that stuff in
is because of >> if you're I if you're alive and breathing
in the United States right now, you understand that the risks
have simply escalated and the United States Congress could act
and so far simply
>> Clearly, this crackshot wouldn't have one tapped Charlie
at 100 plus meters if he understood the danger of guns. Yeah.
essentially like that's what we're Yeah. This guy This guy didn't
understand that guns could be bad. Okay, I got to I got to
That's weird. The rabbi thing is weird. We'll go over it in just
a second. I'm going to pull up the Trump thing. I have to use
the bathroom real quick. I'll be right back. Okay, >> fellow
Americans.
>> For my great fellow Americans, I am filled with grief
and anger at the heinous assassination of Charlie Kirk on a college
campus in Utah.
Charlie inspired millions and tonight all who knew him and loved
him are united in shock and horror.
Charlie was a patriot
who devoted his life to the cause of open debate and the country
that he loves so much, the United States of America. He fought
for liberty, democracy, justice, and the American people. He's
a martyr for truth and freedom and there's never been anyone
who was so respected by youth. Charlie was also a man of deep,
deep faith. And we take comfort in the knowledge that he is now
at peace with God in heaven. Our prayers are with his wife Erica,
the two
young beloved children, and his entire family who he loved more
than anything in the world. We ask God to watch over them in
this terrible hour of heartache and pain. >> Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. >> The two with Goded by youth.
Charlie was also a man of deep deep >> Hold on. I got to
listen. >> And we take comfort in the knowledge that he
is now. >> He is he's telepromptered up. I >> young
beloved children and his entire family who he loved more than
anything in the world. We ask God to watch over >> just
like a glaze session I guess >> in this terrible hour >> which
is fine by the way but I I just it's weird when the president
of the United States does this but he he never misses an opportunity
right he never misses an opportunity and he called him a martyr
which I think is
incorrect if you want to lower the temperature um that's incorrect
okay calling Charlie a martyr is already incorrect if you want
to lower the temperature you let that be decided by something
else okay I think uh I I don't like that. I don't like it.
>> I don't think so. Might be a >> filter. This is
a dark moment for America.
Charlie Kirk traveled the nation joyfully engaging with everyone
interested in good faith debate.
His mission was to bring young people into the political process,
which he did better than anybody
ever. to share his love of country and to spread the simple words
of common sense
on campuses nationwide. He championed his ideas with courage,
logic, humor, and grace.
It's long past time for all Americans and the media to confront
the fact that violence and murder are the tragic consequence
of demonizing those with whom you disagree day after day, year
after year. >> Okay.
Okay. Okay.
Now, this is where
you have to Yeah, it's literally says you I don't Brother. No,
no, no. It's not even
Dude, load up a highlight reel of the people he talks about.
He never He only denigrates people, right? Every one of his opponents
he denigrates, he does this exact thing, too. This is This is
crazy.
>> In the most hateful and despicable way possible. For
years, those on the radical left have compared wonderful Americans
like Charlie to and the world's worst mass murderers and criminals.
This kind of rhetoric is
>> responsible for the terrorism that we're seeing in our
country today and it must
>> This kind of disconnect is actually so [__]
frustrating that like he literally he literally he's so he's
so bad. He is literally the leading the way on all of this stuff.
Like guys, demonizing your opponents like this,
demonizing your opponents like this will lead to terrorism. It's
100% conclusive. By the way, have you heard about the Communist
Democrats and their plan to destroy America? brother. >> Right
now,
my administration will find each and every one of those who contributed
to this atrocity
and to other political violence, including the organizations
that fund it and support it, as well as those who go after our
judges, law enforcement officials, and everyone else who brings
order to our country. From the attack on my life in Butler, Pennsylvania
last year, which killed a husband and father, to the attacks
on ICE agents, to the vicious murder of a healthc care executive
in the streets of New York, to the shooting of House Majority
Leader Steve Scaliz and three others,
radical left political violence has hurt too many innocent people,
>> taken too many lives. Tonight, I ask all Americans to
commit themselves to the American values for which Charlie Kirk
lived and died. The values of free speech, citizenship,
the rule of law, and the patriotic devotion and love of God.
Charlie was the best of America, and the monster who attacked
him was attacking our whole country. An assassin tried to silence
him with a bullet, but he failed. because together we will ensure
that his voice, his message, and his legacy will live on for
countless generations to come today because of this heinous act.
So he's trying to he's trying to cement it as like a he knows
that it's going to pull well, right? This is the reason that
it's it's so I don't know how to pull out of this spiral if I
was an American. Dude, it's it's actually so bad. He's um he's
just going to try to use this to say it is a civil war. We're
in a civil war right now, right? We're in a civil war right now.
And yeah. Oh, by the way, you're here. I was telling somebody
this earlier today. Okay. If this was 2020 Thank God this isn't
2027. If this was 2027, this would be I cannot give up power
right now. I cannot I will hold an election, but I need to run
again because I need to hold the Democrats responsible for this.
It would absolutely be leaning into that, right? If this was
2027 instead of 2025. Thank Thank God if this had to happen,
it happens in this year and we can't do this [__]
Okay, but yeah, he's leaning into like Charlie's a martyr. It
is a civil war. He's leaning into all of it with enough plausible
deniability that he could get away with it. It's like calibrated
well. I I have a feeling that this is just an entirely like teleprompter
speech that somebody else gave him. I don't think these are his
words almost at all. It's like somebody who understands Trump's
tone and then he's just taking the message they want him to get.
Charlie's voice has become bigger and grander than ever before
and it's not even close. May God bless his memory. So what is
the point of lowering the temperature when their leader when
the leader of their side is saying this we're going to be the
most moral corpses ever for real. Well, one I would say it does
seem like it does seem like there's violence from both sides.
You can literally try to get rid of the violence of both sides
and I think you reach people a lot better if you are trying to
get rid of the violence of both sides. You could say, "Oh, what's
the point in lowering the rhetoric?" God, it works so well on
people. Yeah. This is like the exact thing that keeps um
Israel and and Palestine in a forever war, right? Is like you
have people on the Palestinian side who want to negotiate, but
then you know some some extremists go and bomb a bus station
and it's over. Now the extremists on the Israel side say that's
who they are. That's who they all are. We can't negotiate with
these people, right? and everyone just falls for this every single
time. It's just sad, but it will it will work. Um, it always
works. It literally never fails. Congratulations. I'm totally
black now. Um, it's the wrong thing to do, but nobody will be
able to prevent themselves from engaging in this. So, you're
it's like over or sorry. Yeah, it's totally over. You guys are
totally good luck. >> May God watch over his family and
may God bless the United States of America. Thank you. >> People
People aren't smart enough to dodge it. It's uh it's actually
just over for you guys. It's like it's so over. We already covered
Z calling into the Destiny stream. Yeah, we covered it. Uh what
did I have next? Oh, I got the Nancy Mace thing. Let's go. Nancy
Mace.
What was Nancy Mace saying? Some dumb. No doubt. >> Democrats
own what happened today. I am devastated.
My kids have called panicking. They probably all the kids of
every conservative in the country called panicking.
Just because you speak your mind on an issue doesn't mean you
get >> Then do by that logic do Republicans own the shooting
of the two Democratic lawmakers in Isn't this isn't this on both
sides? >> Are you kidding me? >> No, I'm asking.
>> We don't know what condition Charlie Kirk is in right
now.
>> Charlie, I need a shield. Charlie Charlie Kirk is dying
somewhere. Charlie Kirk is dying. How dare you?
Uh, okay. Did that Minnesota guy knock anyone? Those people are
already dead. We don't even have to ask. Listen. Listen. Charlie
Kirk is dying and I'm trying to use his corpse to attack people.
Can you off Jesus? >> Some raging leftist lunatic put a
bullet through his neck and you want >> We still don't
know that. By the way, I Man, that's crazy that people just pretend.
We We used to go through We used to play a game. Okay. Hey, we
used to play a game amongst people on like social media all over
the place where they're like, I bet I bet this is like a Muslim.
I bet that there was a Muslim who drove that car through those
people. Okay, I bet it's a Muslim. And other people be like,
nah, it's a white dude. It's a white dude. And we used to play
this game, but we would hold off.
And now it's like they don't even wait to find out. They're like,
"That was a Muslim. I'm going to report it as a Muslim." Some
Muslim lunatic who hates America. Who's who's like a Wahhabist
Wahhabist jihadist terrorist
bombing freak. okay, attacked our country and like then it comes
out it's a white guy and they just don't ever address the fact
that they said that. Right. But now they just they just say it.
They don't even wait. >> Want to talk about Republicans
right now? No. >> No. I'm asking you you said the Democrats
have this on Democrats own >> But isn't there is there
a problem with polit political violence across the >> Yeah.
We're talking about Charlie Kirk right now. That's the subject
of this that we're talking about right now.
Ah,
this person's a Yeah, a complete ghoul as well. >> This
100%.
And I'm going to say this.
>> God,
these people are so shameless. If it's a groper, they won't be
caught unless it's a trans griper. I don't even know what that
means, bro. What are you saying?
Hello? Are you okay, sir? Sir, are you doing all right? Why?
When they are mostly saying the left is the problem, the left
should tone things down. The right is fine. Oh, sorry. This is
going to be a response to something else, isn't it? Oh, I don't
know. Um, there's no way it's not a leftist. Wait, Benny, again,
the reason I put my money on a right-winger is because it was
actually successfully executed. That's why I would put it on
a on a right-winger. Yeah, definitely anti-ionist. I think for
sure. I think for sure. Yeah, we read the statement already.
Thank you though. Read it, liked it, retweeted it. Calling for
denouncing violence is based. Okay. Being like, "Hey, violence
is bad." That's awesome. Love people who do that. Love people
who can be human for two seconds. Uh, hold on. See, the the king
has spoken. Okay. Despite his father not doing well, the king
has spoken. Let's see what the king had to say. All right. Anyone
surprised at what happened to Charlie Kirk hasn't been paying
attention. Go anywhere, Reddit, Twitter, etc., And you'll find
thousands of unhinged direct calls to violence over politics.
Until it's addressed for what it is, things like this will continue
to happen. I hit the voice. I think I hit the voice pretty good
there, right? >> I think we did a good job. [__]
does he mean by addressed? >> I will address for what it
is. I don't >> Reban Ruben donated $3. Didn't see Vid,
but blood came out his neck like a fountain. A neck fountain.
I think Nick Fuentes had something to do. Okay.
Oh, I get it. If you guys don't know, Fentes, I believe, is Spanish
for fountain. That's uh Jesus. Reuben, Ruben. Jesus Christ, dude.
Asmin Gold video response on O 20,000.
Asmin Gold put out a video. Where's the >> And giving this
>> Wait, where did he drop this? I'll watch it. But >> this
asymmetrical and giving this >> No, this I need the full
thing. He must have posted it on here, right? Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
15 minute. Oh, 15 minute 50-second video. Let's go. Oh, the Taylor
Loren thing dropped today, too. Let's Dude, what a what a Oh,
you know what? Hold on. Don't say that. I was going to say content
cornucopia, but you
>> Hey guys, it's me again, and it's been a little while.
Um, just before I get into the main topic of the video, I want
to explain why there haven't been any videos. My dad has been
in the hospital for the better part of a week now. Uh, very serious
situation. It has required my full attention. And because of
that, I've been on calls. I've been dealing with other people,
talking to members of the family and doing everything that I
need to be to be there for my dad and for my family during this
situation. And because of that, I haven't been live and I haven't
made a lot of videos. I apologize for that. Hopefully, I'll be
back as soon as possible. That being >> I think literally
everybody understands >> said we had something insane happen
today and I was able to break away a little bit earlier and I
wanted to make a video about it and talk about the obvious and
inevitable nature of the assassination of Charlie Kirk. This
happened a few hours ago and it was probably one of the most
gruesome and graphic and this is coming from somebody grew up
on Live Week uh videos I've ever seen. the I I the first time
I saw a video, I thought it was AI generated. Uh the guy gets
shot in the neck and blood is spurting out. I didn't even know
it could do that. >> I mean, this guy's just lying that
he said he was on live league. Okay, this he's just lying. >> And
it was >> the disturbing thing was the the quality of the
video and um the fact that it's somebody you like know, somebody
you have like uh some understanding of or whatever. Like usually
with live league it's like totally faceless people. Not not literally
but figuratively faceless people, right? They're just anonymous
people. You have no idea who they are. In this case it's like
this is a guy everyone knows.
horrifying to see something like that happen in front of a massive
audience of people. Now if you don't know who Charlie Kirk is,
Charlie Kirk has been a pretty noteworthy
uh you know like controversial guy. He's a conservative. He goes
to a lot of college campuses, does live debates. This is a pretty
popular uh format nowadays and uh Charlie Kirk has been popularizing
it and utilizing it now for many years and he's even featured
in South Park recently because of it. Um Charlie Kirk definitely
is not a super radical right-wing person, but I would say that
he's more of the moderate to, you know, kind of extreme right-wing.
Very very I would say lukewarm though in my opinion at least
especially and this is where we're going. Uh, especially compared
to now. Totally Kirk. Definitely. >> Sorry, I pulled up
this Z tweet. Guys, stop sending me the same tweets or or whatever.
Like, I if you're if you're surfing streams and licking the same
thing across streams, don't do that in my chat, okay? um just
if you're because we already covered that >> certainly
is not a super radical rightwing person but I would say that
he's more of the moderate to you know kind of extreme rightwing
a very very
>> like
he's not extreme in terms of like maybe economics or something
he's like a socially he's extremely right-wing >> I would
say lukewarm though in my opinion at least especially and this
is where we're going uh especially compared to now and what I
think is going to happen now because obviously you you these
shootings like this don't really happen inside of a vacuum and
they never do they never have and I think that the situation
that we have right now is that there is a tremendous amount of
political violence that is advocated for promoted and allowed
to exist on social media that has turned up the temperature
is mad. >> Do I sense a son is bad coming? I feel like
I do >> in all political conversations, all social conversations,
and all discourse on the internet in general. >> No, Rook,
you're wrong. Charlie Kirk, who is fairly extreme in his beliefs,
and like he he's probably going to push towards like some kind
of um theocracy. Like he thinks the church should have a way
bigger role. Um I I think he was more extreme. Now, in his specified
views, was he like incredibly extreme? I just don't think he
was moderate. He wasn't a moderate Republican. like he was a
he was just as much of a populist [__] as everybody
else who's like super in with Trump, right? >> To a point
where it's almost unreoverable.
Uh you have people that are out there all the time advocating
for violence, advocating for people to get. Somebody needs to
take care of this guy. Somebody needs to deal with this. I wish
he were dead. >> Uh come on, Asigold. You got to take Somebody
needs to take care of this from us, too. Come on. >> Somebody
do it. the 8647.
>> Something something's got to be done, guys. Something's
got to be done. >> All of the crypto messaging and all
by the doxing, right? Why do you dox somebody? Why do you post
the person's home address? It's to make other people that are
insane, like the person who killed Charlie Kirk, it's to give
them the ammunition they need to kill that person. And >> um
hold on. I don't think Asminold feeds into the violent stuff
at all. Unless I'm misunderstanding. I think the closest he came
to that was some of the comments on Palestine, but I don't think
Asminold feeds broadly into the violence stuff. I don't think
so. To put that person's life in danger. That's why they're doing
it. And so that's the reason why they want to find out the identities
of ICE agents. That's the reason why they want to find out the
identities of Tesla owners like at the beginning of the year.
It's so they can destroy their car and destroy their lives. And
this isn't necessarily a one-sided thing. I think that in the
last 5 years or so, especially since BLM, uh, it's been a like
90% left-wing thing, but that doesn't mean that the 10% right-wing
people are right either. But I do think that now you're going
to see a lot more right-wing people balancing out those scales.
Uh, the fact is that you can take a knife to a gunfight all you
want and you can think that you're honorable, but you're going
to end up being dead. And I think that's what right-wing people.
I think this is this line of this is so thought terminating.
You say this to terminate thoughts, to get people on your side
and terminate their thoughts. Guys, you can't take a knife to
a gunfight. You can have the whole conversation every time. If
you're arguing that we need to nuke Japan, we can have that conversation
a few times. We don't have to have that conversation once, right?
Right. We can happen it multiple times. Yeah. Stop doing the
thought termination of like, "Guys, we uh you need to really
just think about it. They're they're talking this way. We can't
not talk this way." No, you should actually talk through that
whole thought process every time with like everybody, right?
But there's so many people who do this, guys. What What am I
supposed to not take dark money? What am I supposed to Republicans
take dark money? Why would you get mad at me taking dark money?
Right. No, you need to have more of a discussion with people.
You absolutely do. like almost every time because you can't just
have it I I feel like it's so disingenuously used every time
I see it. Like stop criticizing me cuz these guys are bad. Just
look at them. Focus on how bad they are and stop criticizing
me cuz they're bad. They're bad. >> Have done for a very
long time. Uh they've tried to speak above the political violence.
They've tried to uh advocate above it and not try to stoop down
to that level. But the issue is that a lot of these social media
companies have expressed literally zero desire to even do the
bare minimum of moderation. Uh I think that two of the I don't
even think they should moderate these people if they're doing
like coded calls to violence. I think they should just demonetize
them. That's what I think you should do. You should take away
any monetization they get from your platform for a little bit.
What is this audio? Asmin Gold did this I think on his webcam
microphone or some [__] I don't know what he's doing.
Okay. The worst actors are Twitter or X and uh Reddit. Uh both
of these platforms are full of a bunch of extremist nut jobs
that not only should have their accounts banned, but they should
probably be put in mental institutions.
And I think that now I find it to be kind of interesting taking
a step back for a week or so and seeing how many people Oh god,
don't do the techone thing. Don't do the techone thing. Oh my
god. God, if I had to listen to this guy go, "Guys, I unplugged
from the matrix for like 3 hours and now I can see how how blinded
everybody else is by hatred. Shut the [__] up." >> We're
coming around to the inevitable reality that this is the only
path forward. Uh there are so many people in society now that
are just completely unhinged, undermedicated,
and really just completely insane that you can't have a person
like that running wild out in society. They cause problems for
themselves. Not to mention everybody else around them. And I
think that the society, we need to have an honest conversation
about how >> Dude, Tech Jones got me blocked. I would have
retweeted this. Why did he What the I don't understand. This
is after Charlie Kirk got shot, too.
I don't It's a bit, right? It has to be It just has to be a bit.
I don't understand. There's like Is it just important to like
be different from other people? Is that the thing that's most
important? You just tweet something out that's different from
what other people are tweeting out and you just want to get Is
he wrong? Dude, it's so stupid.
It's so stupid. No, that didn't happen. Jacob, uh, I got blocked
by him for joking for making jokes at his expense a long time
ago, bro. It's so crazy. It's so crazy, dude.
I just I don't understand the tweet. >> How to deal with
these people in a way that, and I'll be real, um, I don't really
care about the people that are crazy, their their well-being
and the way that, you know, things are for them. Of course, obviously,
I wouldn't want it to be bad, but it's certainly not important.
Uh what's really important is all the people who aren't crazy,
making sure that people that are not crazy, that are good actors,
that are law-abiding citizens, are able to live a life of peace,
a life of uh prosperity, and a life without fear of going on
the subway, for example, as the recent event as well. Uh and
I think that every single person in the world deserves to live
in a to secure our a future for
>> place like that >> there's some there's some okay
you secure the subway lines for white children or something like
that >> and uh I don't want to see uh >> I started
I started cooking that that statement and then I my brain shut
off and I couldn't finish it. you know, America turn into a PvP
server. And it sure seems like it is. And I think that in order
to prevent that from happening, we need to have honest conversations
about what do you do with people that you know get arrested 14
times? And it's not even a it's not even >> Oh, Scy, are
you unaware of this guy's normal rhetoric around like flagging
for PvP that he like that's how he talks about violence? Basically,
violence against like random civilians. He says that's like you
didn't flag for PvP. That's like that's literally a phrase he
uses a lot. Was Charlie Kirk flag for PvP? He was not flagged
for PvP. Guys, >> I'm going to question, right? You put
them in jail when you throw away the key and you comp >> You
guys all cringe at flag for PvP when he's just reusing the wire
thing, right? You remember the wire? These guys aren't in the
That's in the all in the game, baby. Okay, that's all in the
game. We all play the game. And then the civilians, people who
are outside of the game, they don't play the game, right? It
It's not cringe when The Wire does it. Is it just that it's like
black people doing it and they're cool and when a white guy says
flag for PvP? It's the same sentiment. It's the exact same >> Tell
them to work and that way you can make the money back from imprisoning
them forever. That's the way that you solve that problem. It's
very simple actually, but for some reason uh the way that that
makes people feel has made them unwilling to look at this obvious
truth. Uh if you look in history, this is what we always done
in history and it's because it works. And the problem is that
now we have so much of the discourse that's dominated by emotional
thinking, that's dominated by the most unstable, the most virtue
signal, the most uh you know ridiculous performative empathy
possible. Uh and that's defining a huge political voice in the
country. Uh this has become a tremendous detriment to everyone.
And I think that with people like the shooter uh that probably
shot Charlie Kirk, with that guy in the subway that stabbed that
Ukrainian woman, or with that trans shooter that shot up the
school, uh, one thing that's common among all of them is that
these people in almost all cases were verifiably nuts beforehand
and nothing ever was done about it. And until we can stomach
the idea of solving problems like that before they happen, we're
going to keep having problems. And I think that with Charlie
Kirk, it's very obvious that the amount of uh, you know, political
violence and advocating for political violence that's happening
on the internet has turned up the temperature and created an
environment and a culture where this type of behavior is normal.
And not only is it normal, but it's actually encouraged. And
the problem is that now people are acting on it and you're starting
to see this happen and I think it's going to continue getting
worse. I don't think Charlie Kirk is going to be the last one,
but I think that we will look at Charlie Kirk's death and see
it as a turning point in this topic. And what I'm really trying
to get at why won't people why won't people stop? Please stop
doing the >> here with this entire point is that right
now we are at a extremely pivotal m pivotal moment. And I think
that what's going to end up happening is that right-wing people
are not going to continue to turn the other cheek. They're not
going to continue to just oh well, you know, this is just a crazy
left-wing radical. I think you're probably going to see right-wing
people doing the same thing to leftwing people. And honestly,
while I don't think this is a good thing, I certainly don't really
feel that sorry for them because a lot of left-wing people have
no problem advocating for violence or at least using coded language
in order to advocate for violence. Uh the fact is that there's
a certain level of intellectual dishonesty that goes on in situations
like this where it's considered, oh well, you know, this isn't
actually what they meant and no, this is actually some other.
No, it is. It is exactly what they mean. uh they're trying to
advocate for people that they disagree with. That's what's happening
and there's no talking around it. And to the extent that you
try to, you're insulting the intelligence of anyone that you're
speaking to. And I think that now you're going to start seeing
a lot of right-wing people end up doing this to leftwing people
now even more because it's very clear that these social media
platforms are not going to moderate this behavior. the FBI, for
whatever reason, just refuses to deal with or have any degree
of accountability for dealing with these obvious terrorists that
are in the country. And because of that, I think you're going
to start seeing an uptick of violence from right-wing people
as well. And this is going to be, in my opinion,
uh I don't really think the word is justified because it's not
justified, but the word is expected. I think it's going to be
expected. Uh the fact is that, you know, again, you bring a knife
to a gunfight, you're going to lose. And don't be surprised when
you keep bringing guns to gunfights and then somebody else decides
to start shooting back. I think that that's what's going to happen.
And I think this is a degradation of society as a whole. Don't
be shocked when you bring guns to gunfights and people start
shooting back. Guys, listen. Don't be shocked when that that
implies that you're already shooting. That implies it was already
gunfight. You already were shooting. Yeah. Don't be shocked if
people start shooting back. >> And ultimately, the real
burden of responsibility here doesn't really fall on influencers.
And I don't think that it falls even on the commenters themselves.
I think it falls primarily on the government. The fact is that
the government, there are already laws that permit uh, you know,
explicit calls to
There's already laws that permit the types of stalking and doxing
that people engage in online. And one of the big things that
is a misconception is that people like me want new laws. We want
any form of extra censorship at all. I certainly don't want that
and I don't know anybody else that does either. But what we do
want is we want the existing laws to be applied and to be enforced
in an accurate and a fair way, which is clearly not what's happening.
And really the government not doing that. And >> does he
wait is he not still talking about like doxing and [__]
here? There aren't like federal laws on this >> and giving
this asymmetrical
in my opinion advantage to leftwing people to fully and fre with
with complete freedom >> like advocate for violence >> uh
practice genuine terrorism on a daily basis and and then you
know congratulate each other about how moral and how good they
are for doing it because of something bad that happened in in
Palestine or something bad that Donald Trump did three years
ago. uh this is just simply a a response. This is what's going
to happen. And so and and I think that that's probably what it's
going to take for these left-wing people to realize what a bad
idea what they've been doing is because until it starts happening
to them until they start having I think I think Twitter used
to be a lot harsher against like doxing and calls for violence.
I think Elon's the guy who came and changed all of that, isn't
he? I think Elon was the guy who was like, "Hey, unless it's
illegal, it's allowed on Twitter." I think Elon's the person
who created the platform that allows this. Like, he pushed the
platform to allow this stuff.
People are their their friends or, you know, their, you know,
like icons that they look up to the same way people looked up
to Charlie Kirk. Um, you know, until they start seeing those
people get killed, I don't think it's really going to be real
for them. And unfortunately, I think that's the path that we're
headed down because of the government and social media companies
and every other seemingly governmental apparatus that has just
completely handwaved this problem and ignored it entirely. So,
uh, the death of Charlie Kirk and the assassination of him should
not come as a surprise to anyone. This should be something that
everybody could have expected. All you had to do is read Twitter
for an hour and you could have told me this would have happened.
Of course. Uh, same with Reddit. And until that core problem
is addressed, you will continue to see a >> Now, will this
core problem be addressed? Will Elon from from the mouth from
the mouth of Elon's god, will it be addressed? Okay, cuz I believe
Elon does respond to the O. No, no, no. He responds to Aszenold's
tweet, right? Elon does respond to that. Anyone surprised about
this? Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Elon just says, "Yes, yes,
yes, master." Yes. Did you see asoldold ratio the out of crassenstein?
Hold on. Asenold reply on something else here today at F at FBI
at FBI director cash at X
you coming after you? You thought you were cute with the 8,647
shirts and other coded calls for violence. Now it's happening
to you. It's not going to stop. Now it's only going to get worse
and no one should have any sympathy for you. Be safe. Uh this
is gross. This is this is gross. This is disgusting.
Sounds like a call to violence. I'd say co-signing this is insane
from Asmin Gold. But yeah. Yeah. I think that's insane. I think
that's crazy. >> Rapid decline in any type of social discourse.
And I'm actually kind of afraid uh to see what's going to happen
next because I think it's just going to continue getting worse
and I don't see the reason for it to stop. And so anyway, um
I wanted to make this video because it's obviously a topic. Oh,
the 8647
stuff is Dude, that's so stupid to pretend that that's like a
call for
>> You know, I've been talking about this a lot for the
past few years now, and I was laughed at a lot, and people were
telling me it wasn't that big of a deal, and oh, they were joking.
They were joking. Well, I I saw the video. That wasn't a joke.
And the reality is that those jokes and everything uh create
a culture and an environment where the actual actions are more
permissible.
And you also have people that are the ones telling the quote
jokes that are talking around uh just, you know, directly,
you know, saying that this is a bad thing and it shouldn't be
tolerated for any reason. Uh you have I I don't want to go through
a bunch of different names, but um anybody, this is the way I
look at it. I'm just going to make a categorical uh judgment
here. uh is that any content creator or anybody like this who
uh has been advocating for violence uh against a person in an
extrajudicial way. I'm not talking about trying people who they
disagree with for treason. This is advocating for the judicial
process to be used against people they disagree with. I think
that's fine. But whenever you have people that are saying things
like a through a bunch of different names, but um anybody, this
is the way I look at it. I'm just going to make a categorical
uh judgment here. uh is that any content creator or anybody like
this who uh has been advocating for violence uh against a person
in an extrajudicial way. I'm not talking about trying people
who they disagree with for treason. This is advocating for the
judicial process to be used against people they disagree with.
I think that's fine. But whenever you have people that are saying
the problem is the judicial process, you are protected from anything
that is not an actual incitement of violence. It's all protected
under the first amendment. There's no reason to go through the
judicial process cuz all of this stuff, all of the coded language
is not even close to an actual incitement of violence. It will
all be protected by the second amend, sorry, by the first amendment.
You don't have to go to like literally nobody will ever try this.
What law are we looking for? >> Things like 8647
or anybody who's advocating for >> Yeah, that's not that's
not an advocating that's not advocating for violence. And advocating
for violence in a coded way is not against Yes. the Brandenberg
test. All of this stuff fails the Brandenburgg test. It will
all fail. It will all be permissible speech. There's no reason
to take any of it to court because the first amendment will protect
all of them. You might as well be arguing for a constitutional
amendment against the number one founding principle of America
that you defend any form of extrajudicial
>> brain damage. Justice
Yeah. Yeah. Extrajudicial justice and basically vigilante justice
on people who they disagree with politically. Um, you have to
realize that all of those people I think have made themselves
acceptable targets. And I think that >> Wait, wait. Oh,
dude. I didn't think
Rhinox keeps saying this guy's looks like he's GIF. Um, I need
to just hear what he said. >> On people who they disagree
with politically, who's advocating for any form of extrajudicial
justice.
Yeah. Yeah. Extrajudicial justice and basically vigilante justice
on people who they disagree with politically. Um, you have to
realize that all of those people, I think, have made themselves
acceptable targets. And I think that there's a lot and millions
of people out there nowadays
that see that. And I think that
um, man, extrajudicial justice, that's really imprecise. You'd
think that this guy would have learned like quite a while back
after his Palestine thing, right? You think he would have learned
not to like say super inflammatory with no precision, with like
zero precision. This guy's got like 2% accuracy, okay? He's got
absolutely no plus chance to hit at all. Okay, he is like totally
debuffed. His accuracy is at 2% and he he can't make statements
effectively at all. And he just says [__] like this
like he doesn't know what the laws are. He doesn't know how freedom
of speech applies to any sort of court case. He's like, "Yeah,
I think these people should be punished to the full extent of
the law." They are already being punished to the full extent
of the law. the lat has no power over them whatsoever. Asmin
Gold >> that that should be extremely worrying for them
be terri >> you're saying they're valid targets. Hold on.
>> Whenever you have people that are saying things like
or anybody who's advocating for any form of extrajudicial justice
Yeah. Yeah. Extrajudicial justice and basically vigilante justice
on people who they disagree with politically. Um, you have to
realize that all of those people I think have made themselves
acceptable
>> Okay? So any
any calls to violence at all, it shouldn't just be people they
disagree with. It should be any calls to violence. He's advocating
for anything that could be interpreted as a call to violence
should mean you should you are a valid target for violence back.
He's he's kind of, you know, in the spirit of Charlie Kirk. Okay.
What does America need to stop violence? More guns. If I can
interpret, if I can make an argument that I interpreted your
calling for violence, I can do whatever I want.
Dude, I we're just throwing any ideas at the wall to see what'll
stick nowadays, I guess. >> And I think that there's a
lot and millions of people out there nowadays
that see that. And I think that that should be extremely worrying
for them. Should be terrifying. But the reality is that they
have created that environment themselves through their own actions,
through their behavior, and through their own words. You reap
what you sow. And I think that things are about to get a whole
lot worse. So anyway, guys, I wanted to make this >> Jesus
Christ. Dude, this is actually so much worse than I thought it
would be. This is so much worse than I thought it would be.
Dude, this is crazy that he that he's going like this far. Yes.
He doesn't understand how any standard that he ever advocates
for applies to himself. He is totally incapable of seeing it.
He's total totally incapable of understanding it. Now Teone's
video. Wait, Tech's video is uh not this, is it? >> Oh,
it is. Oh, Techone did a video. Oh, okay. Okay, now I'm locked
in. Now I'm locked in. I'm going to get a pop here. We're going
to finish the asthma gold video. We'll go over to this one, dude.
Oh, there's like infinite on this. There's infinite
all over the place. Anywhere we look, there's somebody saying
something stupid. Let's go. Okay, hold on. Hold on. There's one
other thing I was looking at here. Give me two seconds. Oh, there
was this real quick. Okay, we need to do Asmin Gold and then
I got a clip and then I No, I don't got a clip. Never mind. Talk
about it. And that's about all I've got to say. So, I hope to
be back soon. I'll record videos when I can here and there, but
for the most part, as I said before, uh my dad has had so many
really serious issues going on. Uh I need to devote my full attention
to making sure that he's healthy and taken care of. And so as
much as I look forward to streaming, uh, this has to take priority.
I don't have a time frame. It will probably be a matter of weeks.
>> Like I think this video should have you automatically
demonetized on YouTube. Your content should be demonetized automatically.
Like literally, you could just build AI filters to say, but not
not demonetized like just the video. Your account should be demonetized
for like a month. If you're openly saying violence is okay in
any circumstance, automatically for a month demonetized. No money,
right? And what is that taking away from Asmin Gold? That's probably
taking like thousands, tens of thousands, hundreds of thousands
of dollars away from Asmin Gold. Hundreds of thousands of dollars
in fines every time he says stupid like this. I think he should
still be allowed to talk. I don't think you should actually deplatform
him cuz it's not a direct call of violence. And and even like
some of this stuff like you could make arguments around it, but
if you're like playing it cute, if you're playing it cute, I
think you should lose all of that money >> and maybe not
even that long until I'm back regularly. I would draw the line
at explicit incitement versus implicit. I think they have to
start backing people off. And I don't think it should be like
long periods of time right off the bat, but you have to start
backing people away from the line because the problem is you
are monetarily incentivized to create inflammatory content that
upsets you, upsets your viewers, and then say something that's
over the line to have a hot take. You're totally monetarily incentivized
to do that. And until you get rid of the monetary incentive to
say the most things possible, this will continue to happen. like
like these people will do the things they're going to do. They'll
continue to raise the temperature, right? You just eliminate
the incentives entirely. But now, I don't know how you actually
enforce this effectively because to me, obviously, you start
putting this into place, it's probably going to get abused in
the same way other things do and it's probably going to end up
being like partisanly enforced on different platforms in different
ways. So, I don't know. I just like something has to happen,
man. You you cannot give people money for total like like takes
that they're they're monetizing the downfall of your country.
That's what they're doing. You have to stop that. You have to
stop monetizing the downfall of the country. I don't know how
I don't know how you get it done. I don't know how you make it
effective. I don't know how you make it like nonbias, but it
has to happen somehow. And so hopefully that's the case. Anyway,
guys, thank you all so much for watching. Uh rest in peace to
Charlie Kirk. another senseless uh death that never needed to
happen. And I think that anybody who was, you know, talking about
this and turning up the heat on any of this type of political
rhetoric and discussing or at least, you know, flirting with
the idea of political violence. Uh I think all those people have
made themselves acceptable targets in all the worst ways possible.
And I don't think that this is a good thing either, but I think
it's happened. So anyway guys, thank you all very much for watching
and uh I guess uh I'll see you soon. Anyway, peace. >> Peace.
Okay, goodbye Charlie. So this is is this preceded? This is 1
hour ago. When did we get white lives matter? We got white lives
matter matter 5 hours ago. So Tech saw Charlie Kirk die. He tweeted
white lives matter and then he made this video. Okay. Are we
going to hear about the demon in in in Tee's heart? The demon
in his soul? Are we going to we hear about this today, guys?
I'm a bitter bitter man. The more I learn about the world, the
more bitter I become. Where is that? I need that quote from the
previous video. Hold on. Uh, Teone. I need I I just need it right
now. I I have to stop everything to find my Teone quote. Okay,
we need uh We need >> Carrying myself is going to be way
different. I am a >> Oh, that was it. That was it. >> I'm
going to be chill. Carrying myself is going to be way different.
I am a bitter, bitter, bitter man. And and you want to why know
you want to know why I'm so bitter?
Because the more you get informed in this world, the more you
realize how disgusting this world is. I I want everybody to know
I'm not taking this break so I can be happy again. Absolutely
not. I mean, I'm doing this because I want to enjoy my life.
I'm
>> bitter
bitter man. Okay. Goodbye, Charlie.
We're here for it. The new techie video. He also released a different
video today. Two videos today. Just to be clear, the other one
I'm sure is going to be stupid, but this one I'm excited for
how stupid this might get. Okay, I'm going to I'm going to hit
play on this. I'm going to grab a pop really quickly. I'll only
be like 10 seconds. >> Sorry about the uh volume on my
phone, but I just have a lot of thoughts about what's going on
in the world right now. You know, I uh got a chest and sternum
tattoo today for 4 and a half hours, and I thought that was going
to be the most pain that I felt today. And then uh >> No
way. Well, in case you didn't >> No way, guys.
Another one of my heroes has died. It turns out Tech picks his
heroes. Okay. By seeing who has died most recently, whose tragedy
he can farm, and then carrying that forward into the future.
All right. When he saw Reckful die, he was like, "This is an
opportunity." When he saw Onision die, that was an opportunity.
Now, he sees Charlie Kirk die. And Charlie Kirk is one of his
heroes. Okay. Having a publicly uh uh like a publicly um what
do you call it? Like viral death is the key to becoming
one of Tecton's heroes. >> And check the um >> Onision
die. Didn't Onision die. Am I Am I crazy? I thought it was Onision.
Onision's the guy who died, isn't he? Or am I getting the wrong
name there? Maybe Onision didn't die. Who is the black creator
who killed himself? It's not Onision. It's a different name then.
Etekica. I think it was Etica he talked about. I was thinking
of Etekica. I don't know why I confused those two. I never watch
any Etekica content. And I don't know anything about him, but
I think I think Etekica is the other guy. That's my bad. That's
my bad. No, no, no, no. It was Etica. It was Etica. It was Etica.
I think he he talked about how Etekica and um he talked about
No, not Anision. Not Anision. I don't know why I confused those
names. That's my bad. It was Etekica and um Reckful. Jesus Christ.
Okay, it was not too mad. Shut up with Touad.
It was not Tumad. Anyway, we're continuing >> the news
or and uh well >> guys, he thought the most painful thing
he did today was his 4hour tattoo. Okay,
the 4-hour tattoo he thought. But then he saw what happened to
Charlie Kirk and then he knew what real pain was. I didn't know
what pain was. I thought the chest tattoo was bad and then I
saw what they did to Charlie Kirk with these deranged leftist
lunatics did to Charlie Kirk in case >> you didn't. >> And
then I really got mad. check the um the news or Twitter or god
forbid you check Blue Sky. Uh Charlie Kirk was assassinated
live
in front of hundreds of people with a bullet to the neck for
about 25 minutes. Uh people thought there might be a chance of
him surviving.
Anybody who saw the footage would know
that was definitely not going to be the case. recommend you not
look into it if you're squeamish. We've seen a lot of death lately,
whether that be the multiple white women who have been slaughtered
like dogs on public transit or in parks. And you have Charlie
Kirk who was assassinated
with a bullet to the throat. What's happening in the
>> But right now is deeply unsettling.
>> Amazing. Let's run back. Whether that be the multiple
white women who have been >> multiple white women now,
multiple white women, not just that one on the on the subway,
multiple white women >> like dogs on public transit or
in parks and you have Charlie Kirk who was assassinated
with a bullet to the throat. What's happening in the world right
now is deeply unsettling. It has
really slowly started to change me how
awful the world is right now. And by the >> oh god, I just
I just felt the full body shock. I just got the uh for the first
time ever. I'm sorry. I have to I am laughing at something else.
Okay, I'm not laughing at him even. I got Link something and
I just got the full body shock. We saw the side profile of Z
for the first time.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I just I just I'm sorry. I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
Oh, this makes the kilo tweet in response to me today so much
funnier. The crimson chin tweet
by my mother's mandible. Steven, this truly This looks very bad
for me. I'm so sorry. I totally lost where I was in the techone
thing. I totally lost my I lost
who was assassinated
with a bullet to the throat. >> It's all right. We're going
back. We're We're covering. >> What's happening in the
world right now >> deeply unsettling. It has
really slowly
>> You can hear him doing the Pirate Software voice. It
has really softly >> to change. It has
>> he's like trying he's he's going to do the voice. He's
just going to >> really slowly started to change me. how
awful the world is right now. And by the way, if you've been
on Blue Sky, yes, in fact, Charlie's death is being celebrated
by far too Oh no.
Teone is doing the aristocracy play.
Tect is in willingly traumatizing himself. Okay. He's going through
he's watching the video of Charlie Kirk dying again and again.
And he's watching he's going on Blue Sky to watch leftist commentary
with them laughing at him, right? He's traumatizing himself by
following the most vitriolic accounts. Amazing. Amazing.
Dude, this level of self victimization is not usually seen. Okay.
It's not really in white people's jeans, not white men's jeans.
He's like pioneering white woman tech for white dudes.
What an incredible What an incredible innovation. Why?
Why? Weird weird tweet.
Weird tweet. Oh, whoops. Crimson chin. We're back. >> Many
people for me to be comfortable with this fact. In case you don't,
>> the white woman tears. No, the self victimization of
just like going and like forcing yourself to to be victimized,
right? Like you didn't have to go look at Blue Sky to watch like
insane lefties who literally only exist. It's literally only
communists on there. You didn't have to go watch them celebrate
this. You didn't have to do that. But he decided he wanted to
do that. He wanted to do that to himself today. Okay, that was
really important to Techone to do that to himself today. All right.
I have to go and be the victim, guys. I got to figure out how
I can do it. Let me go watch all these leftists like celebrate
Charlie Kirk dying over and over and over again. >> Know
who Charlie is? He was a rightle leaning political commentator.
Some might even say he was a faright political commentator because
he's not >> supporting terrorism. So that means he's >> bro.
These people are so out to lunch on all political discourse and
he is commenting on politics like he understands anything. My
god. Oh,
I dude I So what he just said was because this guy doesn't endorse
terrorism, he's a
implying that like there's the only place left of this guy is
like Hassan in their ilk. Like the the actual like communist
or you know socialist leaning people. So there's like all you
just missed America's entire population between these two positions.
Like 90% of America's 95% of America's population you missed.
They all exist. All of them exist. >> Oh my god.
Yeah. Charlie Kirk was one of the few political commentators
who really kept >> 80% of Americans exist between Hassan
and Charlie Kirk. What? It's definitely 90%. It's definitely
90% of voting Americans for sure.
>> Fair. And what I mean by that is he's a commentator
who wouldn't be there to shove his opinions or his thoughts or
his beliefs down your throats or anybody else's. He is someone
who believed in a civil discussion. >> Oh my god.
Um
Oh my god. Teone Tech doesn't know anything about these people.
Teone knows nothing. Techone
is going to be collabing with Nick Fuentes within uh two months.
Like hardcore. He will not be able to resist. Okay. Tecton is
so influencable. He is so He's so like clout driven. He He is
going to be like on a mainstay with like Fuentes in like a month
or two.
100%.
100%. He'll be like softening everything about the guy 100%.
Cuz he he has no defenses. He's just like, "Yeah, Charlie Kirk
was a guy who like really appreciated just really appreciated
like a conversation and he didn't he didn't force anybody's opinion
down their throat." Okay. Or down he didn't force his opinion
down anybody's throat. I can feel myself becoming radicalized.
Don't. That's what radicals want. In hard times, strong people
with deep principles have to stand up. God, I do. I do it. Do
I like risk it? Do I risk it? Like, it's actually
No, no, no, no, no. Unfortunately, that is actually the correct
opinion right now. That's actually the correct opinion. I actually
have to like it. I don't like Arerodite and it's insane that
she'll like stand next to Destiny and say the the correct opinion
and but have no moral backbone to like stand up and and risk
like her money or clout for it, but it is the right opinion.
I'm not going to like the tweet, but it is actually the the tweet
that's actually important right now. Unfortunately. Unfortunately.
Okay. Do it and bookmark it. No. God, Tech's the worst. Techone
is the worst. >> Where he would sit down with a peer where
he'd sit down with someone in opposition to him regardless of
your viewpoint. I can't I can't like the tweet because of Arerite's
like uh trying to pin her like swatting on me. I will never like
that tweet cuz she's like a she's perfectly fine lying about
people who challenge her clout and she doesn't stand on her morals
to like in opposition to her clout. So I won't like her tweets
cuz she's a total piece of [__] But in general that
is the right opinion to have here. >> A pier where he'd
sit down with someone in opposition to him. >> Sure, you
could say this. But hey, I'm I'm looking for anything. Okay.
Look, look for anything >> regardless of your he is someone
who believed in a civil discussion where he would sit down with
a peer where he'd sit down with someone in opposition to him.
Regardless of your viewpoint, he was very much down to talk.
I've learned a lot. >> That's not true. That's literally
not true at all. In fact, there are a lot of people who wouldn't
talk to Charlie Kirk or Charlie Kirk wouldn't talk to. Hassan
was literally going to debate him in two weeks. Yeah, I know
Cissan was going to debate him in two weeks. Um
that is not there are a lot of people Charlie Kirk wouldn't talk
to. Okay, including the guy who will own this guy's mind in like
in like two to two weeks to two months. Okay, would never talk
to Fuentes ever. Would never have a discussion on Israel at all.
from Charlie Kirk recently uh where I watched his debate and
discussion he did recently and it's very nice to see someone
who was willing to put aside their political belief differences
and just talk to people as people and come to a mutual understanding
of why you believe this why I believe that and maybe we can meet
somewhere in the middle or maybe we'll stay on opposing sides
regardless they were just there to present their beliefs I believe
the first talk on the what he was doing at the college campus,
which they're calling a school shooting, by the way. It's not
a school shooting. If you call it a school shooting, you're
>> it's stupid >> assassination. It was a very intentional,
very deliberate assassination.
Um, he was talking about uh what was going on between like, you
know, the black-on-white crime, I believe. I haven't seen the
full video yet, and I believe he was about to talk >> Teone.
Tecton was actively watching Charlie Kirk debates with college
kids, okay? Like uh like some Crowder videos, some change my
mind, okay? He's watching these and he's like, "Dude, this guy
this guy was talking about like black and white crime for the
it's the first time he's ever heard it. It's the first time he's
ever engaged with politics. He thinks Charlie Kirk is like Jesus
when it comes to politics." All right. And then Charlie Kirk
was taken away from him. He just watched his like political Jesus
get crucified.
And Teone's in a rough place right now. Okay. This guy never
engaged with politics at all and now he's using this platform
that he's built to try to engage with politics. Him and Asol,
dude, it's the worst. This guy is amazing. It is funny content,
but like he's had to post this video ASAP without doing a few
Google searches. >> Transgender transgender shootings and
well, how apppropo that's when that happened. I think the dis
the um the feeling of blue sky celebrating a man's death because
you don't share their political views. You are disgusting. No
one, and I mean this, no one deserves to die because they have
a different political belief than you. You can jail them. Um,
I think that's just incorrect. I don't even think he believes
that. I don't think he believes that. I think he would say probably
people who are like terrorists, they have different political
beliefs than you, right? They probably deserve to die in his
opinion. Almost anybody in his opinion, I would imagine anybody
who advocates for the death of other people thinks you uh
is somebody he prove violence on. You jail them. >> And
I mean this, no one deserves to die because they have a different
political belief than you.
You can jail them if you want. If it's truly that severe and
they act on it, but it's it's >> this guy like people just
don't understand America when they say like this, right? Listen,
what did I think it was like was it like Osama bin Laden who
said, "Give me liberty or give me death." I think that's like
an Osama bin Laden quote, right? Am I correct on that? That's
Osama bin Laden. Or is that like spiritually like something like
a concept that America's like kind of founded on? It wasn't one
of the founding fathers who fathers who said it literally, was
it? I don't think it was. But it's like essentially Oh, wait.
It was It was Patrick Henry Henry. It was a founding father.
Okay. Patrick Henry said it. Fers. Yeah. But like people just
don't get it. Like listen, liberty, freedom, these things are
important. You don't just say, "Oh well, well actually, you know,
you can just jail people if they say things you don't like."
You don't have to kill them. Yeah, I guess we should have just
jailed Charlie Kirk. >> it's just a guy who didn't do anything
wrong other than present a different point of view and was honestly
the most civil person to do it. No one else was willing to debate
anybody in the way that Charlie was. No one else was willing
to sit down and talk to people and try to get to a mutual understanding
like Charlie was. He wasn't a >> That's true. There's nobody
like Charlie. Charlie's totally unique in this. Yeah, I agree
with Techone. Actually, nobody would do this like Charlie would.
Okay, this video is so perfectly emblematic of the problem with
Techone.
He doesn't care about being correct. He's just like, I have these
thoughts and I'm going to say them as if they're like really
true and really correct and nobody is going to like just because
I'm confident people are going to like follow me and listen to
me. Yeah, I know. I know, Ry. >> Radical extremist. He
was a very reasonable man and he was slaughtered
and I'm sorry, guys. From the
Zerutski
footage to the Charlie Kirk footage, um I'm deeply unsettled.
However, I'm very grateful that I am still alive. And I want
to let you know that if you're out there, never take your life
for granted and appreciate those you have around you before they're
gone. Because right now there are people being hunted like dogs
and it's deeply unsettling. >> Wait, who's the Oh, white
women. White women being hunted like dogs. I was like, wait,
who's being hunted? Oh, it's white women, right? >> I think
the reaction from the news is an absolute joke. People are trying
to sympathize with killers
to Carlos Brown who killed.
They're saying,
"Bro, dude, find me a clip of this
clowning on Hassan for doing the Arab accent when he's saying
Arab words, okay? Cuz I know it exists. I know it exists." And
this guy just tried to do like the the Slavic accurate accent
to
It's like, bro, come on, dude. >> This is an absolute joke.
So >> people are trying to sympathize with killers
to >> Yeah. He's doing the
in >> Carlos Brown who killed they're saying yeah but what
made him like that? Well you don't understand how he felt. What
the are we doing?
What what are we doing where we are sympathizing with
What? What are we doing when
websites are protecting people from being called fat and ugly
and a [__] >> Dude, do you see how quickly
he brings it back to himself? Dude, Twitch Twitch is protecting
Twitch is protecting Denims and Froggen for me making fun of
them and then they call me a and Twitch will ban them. It's It's
these It's Twitch. It's these websites.
What what are we doing when
websites are protecting people from being called fat and ugly
and a [__] more than we're >> Dude, it's crazy
that I went into the Dean and Parker videos expecting them to
be hyper soy who victimized themselves, who made it about themselves.
And to be honest, Parker did a little bit, but it's understandable
with him being right there when Charlie got shot, like being
in the line apparently to ask questions. Okay, but it's Tee who's
doing it. Teone's the person who is using Charlie Kirk's death
to complain about his Twitch ban. This is shameful
behavior,
>> Punishing people for calling for the deaths of our senators
as well as the citizens as well as radicalizing audiences to
enact violence while recording themselves breaking the law. Are
are we >> I actually don't know that one. Recording themselves
breaking the law. all seeing the same online or are we guys
I have been banned for nearly two months total over the past
4 months for >> he's unironically he released a video to
use Charlie Kirk's death and how disturbing it was to complain
about his Twitch fans dude get this guy
my g I'm I'm about to flag for PvP I'm about I'm literally about
to flag for P for PvP based on this video okay asold's gonna
deem me valid target. This is crazy.
I I'm losing it right now. >> Yet, there are people out
there calling for the deaths of other people, political figures,
and attempting to radi radicalize and weaponize their audience
to hurt people and kill them. >> Who have gone unpunished.
>> What the are we doing? What
>> What is possibly going on in the world today? This is
disgusting. It is. It's It's absolutely
[__] disgusting. It's pathetic. It's a joke.
>> Guys, can you imagine living in a world where they can
call for Charlie Kirk's death? Literally, give me any example
of that happening. But I can't call Denim's a [__]
Can you imagine? We live in a world where people can call for
like other people's death. Okay, Hassan can tweet that gun and
I can't call frozen fat for the 50th time. It's so up. I can
literally feel in real time my >> dude I swear to God if
he
if he calls
sorry if he cries about Charlie dying after this or if he brings
it back to Charlie's death in order to like reinvoke that emotional
that emotionality I'm actually going to lose it okay
I'm going to lose it >> myself becoming radicalized because
this country is >> uh black thug they are way different.
Hassan didn't use the uh the tweet. He didn't do the tweet on
Twitch for one thing. Okay, the one he's that Tecton's talking
about. And then uh beyond that, Tek was warned like a hundred
different times.
He was warned. Critical Rad, you're just uninformed. It's Mr.
Mutton and Dan and nobody cares. But um you're just you're just
uninformed. He was he was told multiple times, "Stop doing this
or we're going to ban you. Stop doing this or we're going to
ban you. Stop doing this or we're going to ban you." And he just
kept doing it. Yeah. Obviously, you can like obviously you can
just totally flout what the admin team is telling you repeatedly
and then get banned and it's not going to be as bad as other
things people get away with on a one-off. Obviously, that will
happen. Forcing me to. These people are forcing me to because
the people in charge are a joke. And it's everywhere.
It's It's everywhere. The system is broken. I don't believe it's
beyond repair,
but this needs to change. We are valuing
people's feelings
over their safety. The worst thing that I've ever done is call
someone fat.
Call someone a [__]
I I can't like who is around this guy that nobody would go, "Hey,
you're going to make a video about how much of a victim you are
right now?" Maybe don't. Maybe don't. The worst. Sure. Sure.
Sure. for sure. In terms of him getting banned, I don't know.
Somebody needs to help this guy cuz like as bad as Asmin Gold
is, I guarantee you Asmin Gold would have the understanding that
you can't optically go live
and talk about like how you're a victim using Charlie Kirk's
death. This is the worst optics. And anybody who doesn't call
this out for the disgusting like self victimization like like
um weaponization of a murder of an assassination that he's virtue
signaling about and he like flips it into virtue sign no sorry
concern trolling over his bands. It's insane. This is an insane
proposition. This is an insane concept. I don't see how anybody
could possibly support this guy. It's so he's like this is the
worst commentary I've seen on this issue so far today. Honestly,
I just wish I find this more disgusting than Asmin Gold just
being like, "Yeah, yeah, uh, we're coming for you leftists. Yeah,
you're all valid targets now." I find this grosser. I find this
more gross than Asmin Gold's video. This is somehow like at least
Asmin Gold might be motivated by like some kind of higher purpose
or some like this. Okay, but this Tetoone video is nuts. and
then said yourself to a chatter and I am one of the most punished
people on the internet
for
what >> I dude >> Goku just tipped $5.
>> I heard your political polarization and violent rhetoric
epidemic is pretty strong. Let me fight it. >> Okay, thank
you for the that is actually an accurate Goku donation. Thank
you. I appreciate that. Okay, I appreciate that Goku doesn't
care about morality. He just wants to fight people who are strong.
I like it. Okay, thank you. Holy [__] This techone
guy. This techone guy >> the worst thing that I've ever
done is call someone fat,
call someone a [__] and then said yourself to a chatter.
And I am one of the most punished people on the internet for
how long I've been
He said he was going to kill that chatter, by the way. Yeah,
he did, didn't he? Yeah, I don't care, Black Ice. I I don't care.
I thought that Z video was super funny. Everybody's trying to
make it about Charlie Kirk. I'm literally laughing at Z for hopping
on a stream and going, "We're so bad. We're so and Destiny trying
to save her." And she she be she's like, "Yeah, as a country,
but we're so man." That's what's funny there. Okay.
Anybody who's calling that harassment is a feel embarrassed.
Feel embarrassed. Okay. It's just funny. and deal with it being
re deal with it being funny >> for and you have people
on the internet calling for the death of people online and falsely
calling people >> he can't even he can't even effectively
like concern troll over Charlie because he just keeps bringing
it back to
every time >> on a daily basis. Do we not understand what's
going on here? >> Dude, listen.
He didn't understand what real pain was today until he saw what
happened to Charlie. Okay, he was getting his tattoo. He didn't
know what real pain was. And we thought that was, you know, he
saw Charlie die, but it wasn't Charlie dying that caused him
pain. Actually, it was him realizing that he suffers even worse
than Charlie did. Okay, that people call him a and he doesn't
get to end his suffering like Charlie did. He has to be called
a every day for the rest of his life. And that's the real pain.
You all have been fed so many lies
that you will believe your entire life because the people in
charge want you to believe those lies. They want to keep you
underneath their thumb and they want you to believe everything
that they're saying is the truth. And you you want to know the
reality is guys, the people who really want you to think that
they're a good person, those are the worst people
they are. And I find it so >> just tipped $5
when Charlie Kirk was shot through the neck. I was shot through
the He might have died, but I have it worse. I lived.
it really is. It really be like that though. Okay,
Tone has to live with the image of Charlie Kirk dying and knowing
that Charlie Kirk will never know that Teone is not a Okay, that's
the reality Teone has to live in. >> So [__]
ridiculous that all these libs who say, "Oh man, we're the side
of peace, understanding, and tolerance." Yeah, it's been very
good seeing all that peace, love, and tolerance while you while
you celebrate the death of a innocent man. And how you make fun
of a
>> civilian being slaughtered on public >> Bring
it back to yourself. Don't you can't just This is the uh this
is the other thing though. This is him weaving those things back
in. Right. Like he's
me the biggest victims guys. Charlie was
I was called a by Teds. Dennos called me a but Charlie was killed
and was and I was called bald dude. It's It's actually It might
just be performance art. I don't know. This guy is like unbelievable.
This is actually [__]
>> What a joke.
I feel disgusted. I feel ashamed. And this was a horrible day
not just for America but for everybody on this goddamn [__]
planet. Something needs to change very soon. >> Okay, brother.
People on this planet got bigger.
People everywhere around the world get for the dumbest every
day. I feel bad for Charlie Kirk. Okay, I feel bad for Charlie
Kirk's family. But that's just an insane thing to say. There
are people who like don't know where their next meal is coming
from. They haven't eaten in like 2 days. You think they're concerned
about a political assassination happening in another country?
What do you mean it's a terrible day for the world? Nobody else
cares. Thoughts and prayers to Charlie's family.
Thoughts and prayers to Charlie himself. You are a wonderful
human >> Rainbow Dash just tipped five doors. >> Techone
is we all need to get percent cooler so that we can love and
tolerate even people like him. >> I don't know about that.
I don't know if there's a time where I could tolerate this [__]
Another Anthony Jesselick enjoyer. No, no, no. That was a Bill
B.
Make new friends if you don't fight. Maybe one day I'll become
friends with the political polarization and violent rhetoric
epidemic.
>> Thank you, Goku. >> You've gone far. >> And
I am so sorry this happened to you, Charlie. If you are watching
this video, I know today's been very hard. It's been hard for
the past week. >> Even I who I'm trying to get myself trying
to re >> He is about to cry. He is about to cry. His eyes
are literally watering.
This might actually be worse than the video where he where he
cried about Hassan calling his dad a rap. This might actually
be worse. This might be even worse. He's reached a new level
of like victimization over nothing that happened to him. He has
taken somebody else's problems and he's turned himself into the
victim. This is so much worse. >> wire my brain and how
I think about things and trying to fix myself. But I see all
this nastiness in the world and it doesn't discourage me. It
motivates me to come back even stronger when I do. Shout outs
to Zach and his dad. I hope you guys are doing the best you can.
There's a lot of pain in this world right now and they're gonna
try to divide us. Stay strong together. If you're watching this
video, I appreciate you. I hope you're doing well. Thank you
for watching. God bless America. God bless you. Have a wonderful
day. And I hope I see you guys soon. Bye-bye. >> There's
no way. There's no way that you could be this narcissistic that
you make this video and you just can't see it at I'm Naruaki
and when I become Hokag, I'll end this political polarization
and violence epidemic. Believe it.